It's Rollback time people.
What is Rollback?
Rollback is the best conversations
from the pre-video, audio only days of the podcast,
brought to you right here on YouTube
for the very first time.
Why are we doing this?
Why we're doing this,
because these conversations are fantastic.
They're also evergreen.
They're very worthy of your attention,
and our story today, our Rollback today
is one of the most inspiring in the history of this show,
as a conversation with Charlie Engle.
As an alcoholic and crack addict living out of his car,
it took gunshots in his Toyota 4Runner
and the birth of his son in 1992,
in order to prompt Charlie to seek sobriety.
And for soulless during as early years
of achieving a foundation of sobriety,
Charlie turned to running,
which becomes his salvation.
Charlie then goes on to clock a handful of quite impressive
top 10 finishes at a slew of prestigious races
and accomplished in absolutely astonishing 111 day,
4,500 mile run all the way across the Sahara desert.
Life was good for Charlie,
until that is a federal conviction
for mortgage fraud in 2010,
that ends up sending Charlie
to a West Virginia Federal Prison for 16 months.
It's an incredible story.
Charlie is one of a kind.
He's a world class talker.
He's a master storyteller.
This is a guy who's run across deserts.
He's summited ice covered volcanoes.
He's swam with crocodiles.
He's overcome crack addiction,
even survived a stint in federal prison.
And along the way, even through the lowest of lows,
he's maintained this incredibly positive outlook on life.
He's also a model of service,
helping countless people who struggle with addiction,
achieve sobriety.
So here it is.
From episode 67,
recorded all the way back from January of 2014.
My conversation with the incredible, Charlie Engle.
How you doing?
I'm doing, I'm doing great.
There's a lot going on right now.
There is man.
I appreciate you taking the time
to swing by the house on your way North.
Well, based on this beautiful setting
right here, you can ask me to swing by anytime you like.
Right, it's cool.
We're sitting in the garage.
It's gotta be like 74 degrees out or something like that.
We have the door rolled up,
which is why you can hear the leaf blower guy
or whatever's going on.
(Rich laughing)
Yeah,
I think it's 74 North Carolina too right now.
Negative 74.
Right.
Maybe, you know, beautiful day here.
I know that rest of the world is,
is gripped in a polar vortex,
but we're pretty lucky here.
I feel bad for them right now,
but I'm gonna let that go.
Yeah.
Just for the minute,
and just enjoy where I am.
Right.
Be present Charlie.
(Charlie laughing)
Right?
Wait, have you,
you been talking to Astacianna back there
'cause being present has not been easy for me lately.
It's not my default,
but I've been told that it's a better way to live that way.
Yeah, I hear that too.
(Rich laughing)
I'm gonna try it sometime.
Yeah.
So you're getting married.
I am, I'm getting married in three days.
So Saturday up in Big Sur,
to beautiful woman, Astacianna Hatcher-
Yes.
Sitting over behind me.
Sitting behind you.
I can verify that she's quite lovely.
I'm just really glad
that she hasn't gotten a chance to speak
to all that many people who know me,
up until now.
Right.
That's why you're racing it,
marry her as soon as possible-
Right, right.
Before she finds out.
Trying to keep things isolated.
Yeah, right.
(Rich laughing)
Good man.
And there's, you know,
there's so much to talk about.
I just tweeted out that we were gonna sit down and talk,
and I was just thinking,
and there's so many things I wanna talk to you about.
We could be here all day, you know,
I mean so many points of interest,
and relatability from the addiction story,
the recovery story, the ultra running,
the epic sort of adventures
that you have in the works right now.
I mean, I don't even know.
(Rich chuckling)
I don't even know where to start,
but I guess what I'd like to start with is
what's about to happen.
You're about to embark on this cross country run,
this attempt to break the,
break the world record for fastest guy
to run across the United States.
So let's talk about that a little bit.
Great, yeah, I'm calling it Run2Boston,
and it's because I'm running to Boston.
Yeah.
(Rich laughing)
Right.
(Charlie laughing)
It's very creative title, Charlie.
You know, it's the way I work.
So no, but I'm along with
a good friend of mine, Andre Kajlich.
We are going to begin at the LA marathon
when the gun goes off
and run the marathon in LA.
Unfortunately it goes-
That's March 2nd?
March 9th.
Okay.
Yeah.
And unfortunately, it goes East to West.
You're gonna have to double bounce.
Which is really annoying.
(Rich laughing)
I mean, it seems like such a small amount of distance,
but it goes, yeah, East to West.
Well, if you,
if you miss breaking this world record by four hours or so
then-
That would be bad.
We can point our finger at that, right?
Yeah.
But we need the mileage anyway.
So it's actually, okay.
So we'll start there,
run to Santa Monica, and some symbolically,
you know, be at the coast right there,
and then turn around and head back
when everybody else is enjoying their beer and bagels
and continue running that day.
Andre is actually-
Andre Krajlich?
It's actually Kajlich.
Kajlich, uh-huh.
Yeah, and Andre,
I wrote about him several months ago in Runner's World.
I did a feature for Runner's World about Andre.
He and I met in Brazil just a year ago,
during the Brazil 135,
sort of a Badwater sister event over there.
And I come across this guy,
20 miles into the race,
who's in a wheelchair
and he's going up this incredibly steep climb.
And I'm like, I'm seeing him like I'm seeing a,
I don't know, some sort of,
you know, ghost out in the middle of the jungle.
I get closer, and indeed he is in a wheelchair
going to speed.
So he's like, it's like an off-road wheelchair.
Exactly.
He's put off-road wheels on this
somewhat standard racing style wheelchair,
a little more upright than the ones you see,
like in the Boston marathon.
And he's going up this hill.
And he is actually got a guy with him,
a crew member who has a knee in his back.
So he's not helping him at all,
but he's making sure that when he rolls forward six inches-
Right.
That he doesn't roll back.
I was gonna ask if there's some kind of
breaking mechanisms-
There's not.
To prevent you from going backwards.
There's not, he needs,
he needs to work on that but,
and I come up and I speak to him for just a second.
And I continue on up the mountain
and I'm with a friend of mine, Chris Roman,
we're running next to each other,
and Tony Portera,
two guys have done Badwater before many times.
And I will freely admit,
I turned and looked at them and I said,
there is no way in hell that that guy
is gonna make to the finish line.
It wasn't a-
How many miles in were you?
Yeah, we're like 20 miles in.
All right.
And I know what's coming.
We hit these jungle portions where
there were muddy, single track,
you know, I mean, not the kind of thing
you can be in any sort of chair.
Right.
When he got out of his chair,
tethered the wheelchair chair to a,
you know, to a tether, literally went on the ground.
He'd go 50 feet up,
pull the wheelchair up behind him,
go another 50 feet, pull it up.
Oh my God.
Anyway, 62 hours later, he finishes this race.
And I went and asked him if he would mind,
if I pitched a story to Runner's World about him.
And he said, "Sure."
And I did, and they loved the idea.
And he was the,
he was the first in a series of stories
that I'm doing called Hard Won Wisdom,
where most of the article is really their own words,
quotes from them.
But Andre and I started talking about,
I told him, I said, you know,
something I'd really like to do is to take another shot,
'cause in 2008, I tried to break this same record.
Right.
I said, I'd like to take another shot
at the transcontinental record.
Would you be interested?
I just asked him if he'd be interested in doing it,
'cause I thought it might be cool for,
you know, for a guy in his position
to take a shot at that record too.
He calls me back a couple of days later,
and he's the one who said, "Hey, I was,
I was just looking at the calendar
and did you know that the LA marathon
and the Boston marathon are 44 days apart this year?
(Rich laughing)
I'm like, wow, that sounds like a terrible idea.
Yeah.
Let's do that.
Well, the thing about that too,
is that at least
the cross country running record is what is it?
46 days.
It is.
Close to that, right?
Correct.
But the cross country wheelchair record
is like 71 days-
Yeah.
Or something like that.
So he's looking at, oh yeah, I'm gonna cut this in half.
Yeah,
I don't wanna be overconfident on his part,
(Rich laughing)
because he wouldn't like it.
But I mean, I think no, well, yes, pun intended,
the wheels would've to come off for him
to not break-
To not break it.
Right, 'cause he's just,
you know, he won the,
he won Kona and the
hand cycle division a couple of years ago,
not this past year, but the year before.
And he's just a,
he's a tough guy.
His story is amazing.
You know, he lost,
he lost his legs.
Wasn't born that way
and didn't fight in any wars,
had a crazy, almost unexplainable accident in Prague,
went out with some friends and had a few cocktails
and went his own separate way later that night
and ended up falling off a train platform onto the tracks
and got run over by five-
Oh my God.
Subway cars.
And it took one of his legs all the way up to the hip
and the other one mid femur and broke every rib on one side.
And I mean, there's absolutely no,
no logical reason
that he should still be alive after that accident.
But he, you know, he's gone on to not just live a full life,
but a really a fully functional
or more than functional life.
And so I'm-
That's amazing.
I'm excited to have some,
you know, company like him.
It's very,
it's very humbling.
And I think, again, that he'll,
he's actually gonna attempt this record in a,
on a basically stock wheelchair,
like a street wheelchair.
You're kidding, not with the zip wheels on it
and the whole thing?
No, no.
Why is that?
Why is he handicapping himself further?
I think it's a message in a way.
I mean, he wants to,
he wants to say,
'cause he is these racing wheelchairs are really expensive
and there's a lot of folks out there who are in wheelchairs.
And the idea that you can't have exercise
is that you can't be active,
because of that is something that he
feels very strongly is not the case.
And so, you know, he'll have to make some modifications
and it may not be, you know, fully stock,
but it will certainly be as close to it as he can make it.
Wow, that's amazing.
And just, you know, in case people
are not comprehending what we're talking about here,
the intention is to,
you're basically gonna have to cover about
70 miles every single day
in order to cross the country in 44 days
and that's running or wheelchairing,
rolling 70 miles every single day without any rest day.
So how do you even begin to approach that,
not just physically but mentally?
(Rich laughing)
(Charlie laughing)
Yeah, I mean.
Those people that know me know that the mental part of it
is that that is the big question question.
And it may just be that
I don't have enough going on up there
to really think about it.
Right, I mean to backtrack
when you ran across Sahara, that was what?
111 days or something like that, right?
So you've gone more days,
but that was around 40 some odd miles a day, right?
It was gonna be a record
if we could make it all the way across,
which of course we did.
Yeah.
It was going to be a record,
whether it took, you know, 75 days or 150 days,
it would be a record.
So when the inevitable logistical
or physical problems came up,
they didn't really curtail the possibility of the record.
The only thing that would do that would be if,
you know, if Libya hadn't let us-
Right.
In Libya.
In this case, and if we had a bad day in Africa,
we could, in fact,
I could call it, you know, a short day.
I could say, okay, today we're gonna do 40 miles
instead of 50 or whatever.
And that's just not the case with Run2Boston.
We have to cover 70 miles every day,
and I made a lot of mistakes in 2008.
When you're you and Marshall working that-
Correct.
The run across the US.
Yeah, I just, it was, you know,
one thing is I spent a ridiculous amount of time
before that expedition.
I mean, for six months
having to deal with almost every aspect of the production.
It was a film.
There was, you know,
me dealing with my own training and all of that.
And I really just didn't,
we had a great production company,
Next Productions that was doing the production of the film
and they were awesome,
but I was really left alone for all the rest of it.
This time I have a partner in Andre,
who is equal in his approach to the way we're doing this.
And he is taking on, you know,
a lot of the planning and logistical tasks.
And in 2008, I was left to do those myself,
and I also over trained.
I made the mistake that I tell other people-
Right.
Don't do all the time.
I was just-
Well it's 'cause it has to be so daunting.
And so fear provoking
that you almost can't help yourself from over training.
I need to run 500 miles a week
(Rich laughing)
when I'm crossing the country.
Yeah.
500 miles a week-
Wow.
And that's for six weeks in a row.
And that is an absurd,
if I actually think about that,
I would recognize that it's simply not possible.
I mean, and-
So it's back to the moment.
It's back to the moment.
Being in the present moment and being in the now.
I mean, we had an interesting conversation on the phone
the other week.
You were talking a little bit about this
and you were saying in sort of reflecting back upon
how you over trained last time,
and this understanding based on your experience that,
that the body will adapt.
You just have to get through the first two weeks,
and then the body almost sort of says,
okay, I get what's going on now.
You're trying to kill me.
Kind of adjust,
but you've gotta take those first couple weeks
really easy and cautiously.
Yeah.
And the first time I was absolutely a,
a slave to the schedule,
like if it said we had to run 70 that day, I ran 70.
When had I stopped at 60,
I might have actually salvaged the decent night's sleep
and whatever.
I just wasn't willing to change it.
This time, what I love to run 70 on all those first days.
Absolutely, because any day I don't run 70
is another day I've gotta run farther than 70,
but the reality is if I destroy myself
in the first two weeks, then it's a moot point.
It's done.
It doesn't matter what happens after that.
So I've been working actually with Jeff Galloway.
He's been kind enough to help me with some training programs
that initially made no sense to me at all,
because Jeff believes very strongly in
sort of a run walk approach
when he's training people for marathons.
And when I reached out to him to say,
"Hey, here's what I'm doing.
You know, can you help me figure out a way
where I can actually cover
70 miles a day in 15 hours or less,
get, you know, some time to eat,
get a quick massage
and hopefully get a minimum of seven hours of sleep.
Can you help me?
And he absolutely stepped up
and said that he thought he had a plan for me.
And he has given that to me,
I've been using it for a few weeks now.
And it's very strange as a runner sometimes to
walk, you know-
Right.
To sort of fast hike,
which I actually do pretty well,
but to slow it down and realize that the goal of course,
is to get to the finish.
I mean, it seems counterintuitive.
And yet at the same time, it seems completely elementary.
If you just have to cover those 70 miles,
between when you wake up in the morning
and when you go to sleep at night,
it seems logical to me that the best way to do that
is to incorporate walking into it.
And even after I crude Badwater this past should be like,
well, what, you know, what is it like?
What kind of pace are these people running?
And I'm like, you don't understand like,
there's a lot of walking.
Every time there's an incline, people are walking.
They're marching.
They're doing a fast paced hike or what have you.
So to me, it seems like that would be,
of course, that's the answer to pacing yourself
all the way across the US.
Well, Badwater's a great example
because when I speak to audiences very often,
one of the first questions I'll ask is I'll say,
"Okay, who in here can run an 11 minute mile?"
Most everybody in the room raises their hands.
Yeah.
I'm like going just 1 mile, 11 minutes?
And they're like, everybody's got their hands up.
Like, okay, if you could do that
for every mile at Badwater,
you would set a new course record.
You wouldn't, yeah.
(Rich laughing)
You know you wouldn't just win.
You'd set a new course record,
and go looking around, going what?
I'm like, yeah.
I said, it's also, you know,
it's like running on the sun and it's crazy hot.
And there's other things that just happen
that you can't imagine would happen.
But in Running America,
I mean, Running America back in 2008,
what I learned, I tried to be proactive
and account for every possible thing that could go wrong.
And I think I did that to a certain degree,
but every possible thing did go wrong.
And so while I was,
while I had acknowledged those things might happen,
I really wasn't completely prepared for what to do about it
when they did.
This time-
Like what would be an example of
something going wrong?
You know, well, the best example is
three days before that run started,
I actually was diagnosed with a staph infection called MRSA.
And I'd never heard of it before.
I didn't even know what it was.
I'm like, okay, little staph infection.
I'll take some antibiotics.
The doc who was with us actually said,
"Look, you really can't take antibiotics right now.
First of all, they probably won't help.
But if you do, they just destroy your system
and you're getting ready to try to run
70 miles a day."
Right.
So I'm not sure
what I could have done any differently there other than,
not getting the hot tub but
I think that the-
And ultimately, that's what
that pulled you out of the race, that infection.
Well, it was.
And I had 20 different injuries that took place
that are fairly normal, most were overuse injuries.
Tendonitis, blisters, I mean, you name it.
Things that are fairly common, but you deal with them.
And as I said before,
the body has an amazing ability to adapt to stress
and to overcome those things.
And one after another of these,
these injuries that the doc did an incredibly
great job of helping me,
and they all went away, but one,
and I had this tendonitis in the front of my right ankle
and my right foot had gone numb basically.
And he basically said, "One day, look,
it's gonna be permanent."
The nerve damage here is going to be permanent
if you keep running on it.
And I still have three toes that are numb-
That are numb.
Numb foot.
But, you know, it's,
and I against everything inside me,
I've made the decision
to stop at that point.
I jumped on a bike actually
and rode the rest of the way across the country
and supported Marshall
and was as good of a cheerleader as I,
as I could be for him
and hopeful that for the project overall,
that he would be successful.
Right.
And he was, he did make it.
So that was great.
But looking back on that and thinking,
all right, here's what I'm gonna do differently this time.
You're not gonna overtrain.
You're incorporating this run walk method.
What are some of the other things
that you're gonna do a little bit differently?
Well, nutritionally,
I'm really going at it differently.
I've always had the attitude,
honestly, that calories are calories,
especially during a race.
And my joke was in the Sahara even,
there was a time when it seemed like, you know,
everyone might quit,
(Charlie laughing)
I might continue on.
And I always made the joke that if I can get,
some candy bars and a camel to go with me,
then I'll be fine.
Let me go.
This time, very much thanks to Astacianna,
I'm looking at my nutrition a lot differently,
and I'm a vegetarian and have been for many years,
but this time I'm taking that more seriously
and realizing that I do need to fuel my body properly
for something like this.
And not just assume that because I eat,
5,000 calories worth of junk food in a day
that that's going to sustain me-
Right.
In the long term,
but actually Badwater in hundreds and some of those things,
to a certain degree, you can get away with that.
You need to eat some good food, of course,
and have good nutrition, but you can get away with-
Yeah, 'cause you're not getting up
and doing it day-
Exactly.
Day after day after day.
But that stuff's gonna add up for you.
And, you know, I think a lot of people don't realize,
and you're doing a multiple day event.
When you're eating,
you're not eating for how you're gonna feel
in the next hour.
You're eating for the following day.
Yeah.
And you have to always be bearing that in mind,
even if you're not hungry,
making sure that you're on top of that stuff
and you're not running into too much of a deficit.
Yeah, it's not about bonking.
Like I'm not worried on-
Yeah.
Any given day about bonking,
because I'll take in enough calories hour by hour too,
for that not to happen,
but it is how am I gonna feel later in the day
and how am I gonna feel tomorrow?
And well, really the answer to that,
is I'm gonna feel like crap, right?
I mean, there's no doubt.
But how do you minimize
just how crappy-
Yeah.
You're gonna feel?
Minimizing it and-
So what are some of the foods
that you're gonna be relying on?
Eating things that are, for example, real bread,
Ezekiel bread and things that
my dad of all people said something to me today
that was funny and he was quoting a nutritionist.
So I can't remember his name, but,
and he said, basically,
if it won't, you know,
if it won't rot, you shouldn't eat it.
(Charlie laughing)
(Rich laughing)
And kind of the philosophy of eating things.
I've found that when I cut dairy out almost completely
a long time ago,
you know, now if I were to dare,
I made a big mistake, probably five or six months ago,
there was some regular milk in the refrigerator.
We were out of almond milk,
and, you know, I used it on a bowl of cereal,
and it freaked my stomach out for about two days.
Yeah.
And I learned that, of course,
not only is that not right for me,
but it's, you now, milk is not something that we
sort of naturally-
Right.
Are meant to drink.
We teach our bodies to tolerate it
by drinking it all the time, but-
It's also quite inflammatory too, and acidic.
Yeah.
So when you're trying to
kind of repair your body as you go,
not really the best thing to be taking in I don't think.
Sure.
Well, and I am a,
I think I'm a pragmatist when it comes to inflammation.
I take, you know, I take fish oil supplement,
Ascenta is a company that I've been using for a long time.
And I think they have a really pure product,
but I'm also taking Advil.
I mean, it's a combination of things,
because with the sheer volume of miles
that we're talking about in something like this,
it is my job as much as anything to keep
inflammation down to a minimum.
I use Arnica regularly, which is, you know,
which is great both as a topical gel
and then also as a sublingual pill.
And that is a natural anti-inflammatory.
I'm a big believer that those kinds of things
can make a huge difference.
And then for look-
Yeah.
Just the obvious things,
fruits and vegetables,
and I do eat bars of all kinds of different types
and out there I'm not gonna really use gels and such,
because it's, you know, I don't ever really need that-
Yeah.
That instant rush.
Yeah, you're not doing interval training.
Right.
(Rich laughing)
Yeah.
I don't need the instant rush to get over the,
you know, through the wall.
I need something that's long term sustaining.
Right, like a lower glycemic version of a sugar,
so you keep going.
Absolutely.
So, you know, and you know what?
The rest of it is mental.
I mean, my friend Ray Zahab from running this era,
it's one of the best quotes ever that,
these things are 90% mental
and the other 10% all in your head.
(Rich laughing)
It's true, man.
Well, I mean, it's pretty exciting.
I just, I can't even wrap my brain around it.
It's gonna be quite an adventure.
Where are you at in terms of sponsorship
and kind of having all the Ts crossed
and the Is dotted to have the crew all sorted out.
Yeah, it's a daily work in progress right now.
So we're only a couple of months away
from the start of this expedition.
Yeah, clock is ticking.
And we are,
I feel incredibly lucky just a few weeks ago,
a group called The Campus Agency in Boston
actually came on board to really try to run the ship here
and bringing in sponsors that made a lot of sense for this
and their connection, of course, to the City of Boston
and to at least tangent tangentially the bombing
from last year.
I mean, this, you know,
this run, many, many things are gonna happen
around the Boston marathon this year,
to both honor and acknowledge-
Of course.
What happened last year.
And we certainly aren't, you know,
we want to just be a respectful part of that.
And the Run2Boston is absolutely though to
support Boston in a general sense
and support running.
I mean, we, you know as well as I do that,
I'm biased of course, but runners are
by nature, resilient and stubborn.
And, you know, if somebody does something
as heinous as that was last April,
the response is going to be overwhelmingly
to make a positive move towards
rejecting anything that would
dampen the spirits of an event like that.
But overall also acknowledging me.
People lost their lives.
They were permanently changed.
Some of the people that survived, of course, lost,
lost limbs, and that affected not just them,
but families, their whole families.
And I think it's a critical thing for us-
Yeah.
To just acknowledge that
and just say that-
You weren't there,
you weren't there, right?
I wasn't.
Yeah.
No, I wasn't.
Like everybody else or those that weren't there,
you know, the news was,
I would say that was as fast as any news has ever traveled
given the way-
It was crazy.
Yeah.
I was actually at CNN headquarters in New York City
sitting with the news producer friend of mine,
and, you know, in the offices,
they all have the TVs on, right?
They all watching TV as a,
and when it happened
and I watched CNN like jump on the story
as it was unfolding live,
and it was insane how quickly they got on top of it
and stuff was broadcasting live from the moment it happened
to, you know, editorializing it.
Yeah.
Crazy, you know, across the world.
No doubt.
Well, and, you know, as it should be.
I mean-
Yeah.
They certainly,
they certainly spend an incredible amount of time
and energy on-
The Kardashians.
Yeah, exactly.
(Rich laughing)
On things that you just roll your eyes
and shake your head.
Yeah.
It's like really?
And, you know, and I am,
I'm biased by everything about Boston.
I've been very lucky to a run Boston
quite a few times in the past.
And one of the things that I say I've run it,
I think five times now over about 20 years.
And so the interesting thing is,
20 years ago I was a much different person.
I was newly sober.
I was 20 years younger, not surprisingly.
Funny how that works.
And all I cared about was going fast.
I wanted to break three hours at Boston,
and, you know, and I did.
And like, that was my big goal.
And then the next time I found that,
I'm like, wow, there's a lot of cute girls at Wellesley.
I should stop,
(Rich laughing)
and at least acknowledge them, you know?
And then the next time it was like,
well, there's a bunch of kids out here
that are handing out orange slices.
I should take those and high five them.
And so, you know, my times-
Becomes more about the experience.
Yeah, my times has changed,
and the point being that I changed,
Boston didn't change.
That marathon course is exactly the same every time.
And that's the beauty of it, you know.
The support of the community and the attitude of the runners
and just everything about it is so,
it's almost an otherworldly experience,
but we, of course, and me in this case,
you know, I've changed.
And that's a cool thing to sort of acknowledge
when you're running on a course like that.
Yeah, and I think it's
kind of incumbent upon someone like yourself
that if you're gonna undertake a race or an adventure,
that it has to be about something more than you,
you know what I mean?
Like, oh, I'm gonna run across the US
while other people have done that,
other people have done it faster.
I'm gonna try to be the fastest,
but you know, why are you doing,
like what is driving you to do?
What is the undercurrent that is creating this compulsion
to show up for this kind of adventure?
And I'm sure, you know,
there's many reasons for that internally.
(Rich laughing)
Maybe your therapist knows-
Yeah.
A little bit about that,
or your sponsor, but, you know,
but to tie it to something bigger than yourself,
like this cause of Boston and you have to do that.
Well, you can, and again, my answers change and it's not,
it is because I, hopefully, I'm morph and change
and, you know, I'm really,
I like to say that
these types of adventures,
these long, very painful,
they're not things that I don't think they're good for me,
like healthy.
I don't people have said, is this,
how do you feel about what is doing to your body?
I'm like, it can't be good for me,
and I'm not,
I'm not the one saying that it,
that it is,
however, it is something I am compelled to do.
And it is probably,
I don't know probably, it's related certainly
to my addictive nature
and certainly an obsessive personality to a degree.
And my lifelong goal has been finding balance
and marrying Astacianna,
who is a much more balanced person than I am,
is part of the,
is part of what I think that the growth
that I've been able to experience over these last few years,
where a lot of things have happened to me.
I've gone through a lot.
Well, I'm fond of saying,
because I believe it so deeply
that just because something seems impossible
doesn't mean I'm not supposed to try it.
Because the likelihood of completing this Run2Boston
and breaking this record,
it's not like I'm sitting here saying,
"Oh yeah, I'm gonna do that."
And it's not about playing the mental game
we sometimes do with ourselves
where we feel like confidence is going to overcome it.
This is too, it's too big.
It's too difficult for that.
And so humbly I say that I am going to give it my best shot
and that I hope that I learned some
more things about myself along the way,
and that I can also acknowledge some positive things,
both in Boston and in other ways and about sobriety.
And we've got some great charitable partners
that are coming on board and really just make it a,
make it an experience that somehow
helps me get along further and be,
you know, be better in general.
Again, back to this theme of showing up
and being in the moment, right?
I don't wanna be afraid,
I am afraid of it.
I am afraid,
you know what I'm afraid of?
I'm afraid that three days into this thing,
let's see, I shouldn't even pick a day,
'cause that makes me nervous.
Yeah.
(Rich laughing)
Some, you know, a few days into this thing
that like, you know, I'm gonna,
something's gonna happen and I can't go on.
And it's like, I tend to,
my successes have been pretty broadly watched,
and my failures-
Right.
Both as a human being
and as an athlete have also been pretty,
pretty easily viewed by anyone that wants to take the time
and all-
Yeah, but you're like,
it's almost like in the world according to Garp,
when the airplane crashes into the house and he says,
I'll buy it.
It's pre-disasterious, right?
(Charlie laughing)
It's never gonna happen again.
So you've had these epic fails,
you've experienced incredible lows in your life.
So the idea of showing up and running across the country
and not making it, it's like, eh.
Yeah.
You know, like I was in jail, you know?
I was a crack addict.
Yeah.
Like what is that?
Who care?
You know what I mean?
I mean, is that water off your back?
I mean, of course, you're afraid and you wanna succeed,
but in terms of perspective and proportion.
Well,
we all think that everyone's watching us too.
Yeah.
Like that somehow what we are doing,
(Rich laughing)
even if you're just a, you know, no matter-
That's a self-obsession of the alcoholic mind.
(Charlie laughing)
Right.
Everybody in the world cares.
Yeah.
About whether or not I succeed at this.
And the reality is-
And at the same time everybody hates me.
Right.
Yeah.
And that may be true,
(Rich laughing)
but you know,
it's certainly not true that every,
nobody else's life is like hanging on
whether or not I complete this thing.
Yeah.
(Rich laughing)
And that reality in some ways is very,
it's refreshing-
Liberating.
Yeah, because I'm gonna, you know, yeah,
this crazy thing happened a couple of years ago
and I end up in prison,
and initially there was a part of me that thought,
you know, wow, this is,
yeah, I think everybody,
certainly anyone who knew me or knew of me at that point
seemed to know that this thing had happened to me,
but then very quickly there were.
Well, it was like giant articles
in the New York Times about it so.
Yeah, yeah.
And in a way that was cool.
I didn't have to be the one to step up and say-
Defend yourself.
This was, yeah, wrong or right.
I let other people do it.
And I'm happy to say that, you know, they did it.
They did it well.
There's always gonna be it,
it is really funny that,
'cause running the Sahara is such an interesting movie
and it's 500 hours of film
boiled down to 90 minutes of documentary.
So people who see that film have a tendency to think that,
that they know me,
like that is me.
Yeah.
Like every, if I yelled at someone or if I-
It was definitely edited
so that you come off on the dickish.
No, no, exactly,
(Rich laughing)
and I don't deny that I am sometimes.
Yeah.
(Rich laughing)
I mean, the thing is that I think
it's fair to say that I have my, you know,
I have my moments, I'll be the first one to say,
I am not an easy person to,
you know, to be around sometimes.
I'm not fair.
I'm driven in ways that are occasionally embarrassing to me.
But certainly as a human being that I,
you know, I say things I wish I hadn't said,
and you know, and all that,
but I think that through recovery
and through a lot of things,
I'm pretty quick also to apologize for my shortcomings,
but not for being who I am.
This is the package that there is.
And it makes me really good at a few things.
I suck at some other things,
it was very refreshing though,
as a strange way to put it to be in prison
and knowing, seeing so many things being written
and printed and talked about out there about how,
how unfair it was and how wrong it was.
I didn't need to say a thing.
Right.
And I want to get into that,
into that part of the story a little bit,
but to kind of backtrack.
I mean, I first,
the first time I heard an interview with you,
it must have been like 2007 maybe,
it was before I'd ever done any of this stuff,
any of the Ultraman kind of things.
And I think it was,
it was either Bob Babbitt or it was,
that guy, Kevin, an endurance plan maybe I'm not sure.
Yeah, yeah.
And the question was something like,
you must get this all the time that, you know, all this,
the ultra running and all of that is just,
you've just transferred your addiction onto your running.
And what do you say to somebody
who accuses you of that?
And you had a really,
I don't know if you remember,
but you had a really fascinating answer to that question
that really stuck with me
because it's something that I struggle with.
And I feel that same question all the time.
Do you remember what you said?
I know what I would say now,
so no, I don't-
I'm interested in what say
What I would say now is,
is that drugs and alcohol absolutely masked everything
that I ever was, no matter what that was.
It was a mask.
It was my way of hiding from anything.
And running and adventure actually shines
this huge, bright light on exactly who I am.
There's no way to mask that when you're running a 100 miles,
eventually during a 100 miles,
you will become exactly who you are,
for better or for worse.
That's not always the best thing so,
but I mean, my feeling today anyway,
is that, did I say something more brilliant back then?
No, I think it was, it was pretty much around.
I can't remember exactly what you said,
but it was essentially thematically consistent with that,
which is that,
when you're using drugs and alcohol,
you're hiding from the world.
You're afraid,
you're cowering,
and when you're running
and embracing these incredible adventures,
you're saying yes to life and you are inviting challenge
and inviting community and inviting,
inviting the opportunity to confront
and walk through fear into your life, right?
You know what?
Acknowledging imperfection.
I mean, I'm as imperfect as any person you'll ever meet,
but I know that through running
and through scraping away those outer layers
that we pretty much all wear all day, every day,
you're running,
once you get to the whatever it is
relatively for each person,
you know it when you see it,
because I don't care if you're just running five miles.
For someone who's never run five miles before,
by the time they've run three miles,
they're thinking,
they are raw.
Yeah.
They're that raw human being.
And that's what I want.
I want to be that raw person and see what's, you know,
what's down there and drugs and alcohol did nothing,
but, of course, hide all of that
and made it impossible to ever have an actual real emotion.
And with running, my emotions are sometimes too,
too real, but I would rather have that any day.
But also acknowledging,
not trying to deny the fact that there's this
addictive compulsive nature within you,
that certainly is attracted to doing that.
And is, you know, drives you towards that
and allows you in many ways to be able to
not just entertain the idea of these feats,
but actually see them through.
It's like, of course, like if somebody says,
well, you just transferred your addictions.
Well, it's like, well, yeah.
Yeah, in many ways that's true.
I can't say no to that,
but it's a way to
access the best part of who you are
by finding out exactly who you are.
I agree completely,
but here's another funny,
I mean, people who tend to be that critical
and tend to, you know, when they,
when someone says to me,
haven't you just transferred?
I usually take that as a criticism.
I don't usually take it as a comment.
I usually hear them saying, something is wrong with you.
Yeah.
And there may very well be,
but I don't necessarily appreciate them saying it.
(Rich laughing)
And the thing is, you know,
it does tend to come very often from people
who maybe haven't gone out there
and push themselves to their limit,
whatever that might be.
And maybe they're just exploring
and trying to figure out if they should,
maybe it makes them feel better
to acknowledge someone else's outcome you're.
Or that you you're doing this
only because you have a disease.
Exactly, something's clearly wrong with you.
And again, I say to them, you are probably right,
but here's a, you know, here's another funny example there.
I think, you know how,
you touched on why like do these things,
and one of the other reasons why is simply because
my hope is that I do in fact become,
that I become better,
that without making myself better,
I certainly don't have the capability
of ever truly helping someone else.
And that's in running and recovery
in any other part of my life.
If I'm focused on other people all the time,
how does that make, you know,
that can't necessarily make me better.
I can do both things in conjunction,
but I use the example of like most of my big runs,
I've had some cause attached water for Africa.
I played a part in raising $6 million to build wells,
and I'm imminently proud of that.
What I helped to build there grew into water.org,
which is Matt Damon and my friend, Gary White.
And I introduced the two of them.
I fought to bring them together in fact,
when they actually, you know,
sort of refused to work together for a while and I worked,
and I'm proud of that.
With running America the first time in 2008,
it was the united way and some other nonprofits.
And I love attaching something
because if I'm going to do something,
why not try to also do some good,
but I'm also honest enough to say that I'm selfish.
I'm really doing this as much as anything
because I, as a human being want to see if I can do it.
And what happens I see very often is that,
people run for charity all the time,
or for nonprofits and such.
And I totally, you know, I'm supportive of that.
I admire it and all of that,
but here's the conversation I hear in offices.
Like the runner is in the office, where they work,
and the runner's telling other people,
yeah, I'm gonna run this marathon.
And people are looking at him who are non-runners
and saying, "Why would you,
I don't even drive my car that far,"
that old say, "Why would you do something like that?"
And that person is then pinned into a quarter and they say,
well, I'm doing it for cancer
(Rich laughing)
or diabetes or for-
It's a disingenuous response
because it's not really true.
Right.
I mean, it's great that they're raising money
for that.
And they're trying to make it
somewhat about something other than themselves,
but yeah, it's not,
there is a level of not being completely frank-
Well, it's okay.
Motivations.
It's okay to do something just because you want to see
if you can do it.
Right.
And I would hope that anybody
who ever toes the line of a marathon or an ultra
or any race for that matter is at least partially driven
by this desire to see how good they can be
and what they can accomplish.
And at the same time, if they can absolutely,
if they can honor something that's important to them
or raise money for it or whatever it is they might do.
I completely support that,
but I'm always telling people,
try to acknowledge the fact
that you're accomplishing something big
and you should be proud of that just for you.
And not necessarily-
Right, to feel comfortable saying,
I'm doing it, 'cause I wanna see if I can do it.
Yeah, I'm a runner.
Yeah.
And I wanna see if I can run 26 miles in X time,
or just if I can-
Yeah.
Survive it,
and not throw up on my shoes,
or, you know,
(Rich laughing)
whatever it might be.
Throwing up on your shoes,
there's nothing wrong with that.
No, there's not.
I think it's a, you know,
(Rich laughing)
I think we're people are biased against those of us
that vomit on our shoes regularly.
Right, right, right.
(Charlie laughing)
All right, well, let's step it back,
I mean, for people that aren't familiar with your story
and in the show notes,
I'll do an introduction to this interview on all of that.
In the show notes on the website,
I'll put links up to some of the articles,
but I do wanna hear,
I do wanna get into a little bit of the addiction story,
'cause personally that's so resonant with me.
Growing up and sort of,
being a college kid and having your needs met
and then just going left on the world,
like what's going on?
I mean, somebody would say you're a crazy person.
Like what happened?
(Charlie laughing)
What didn't happen?
Yeah.
You know, I was,
I was a pretty,
well, I was gonna say I was a typical high school kid,
but I probably was a little-
You kind of had hippie parents though, right?
Yeah, I was a little above,
but I was a little above,
I don't wanna say above average,
but I did a lot.
I played five sports in high school.
You like football captain-
Yeah.
Quarterback, right?
Yeah, and I was student class president,
and then student body president my senior year
and I made good grades and had a good SATs,
and was going to a good college at UNC Chapel Hill and all,
I mean, I like rode and produced a radio show
actually in high school.
I'm sorry a TV show.
A closed circuit show in our high school every morning.
So I mean, I was up at five running.
At six, I was at the radio station getting the AP wire
because we didn't have,
I didn't have a Blackberry or an iPhone at the time.
And I'm doing all these things all day, every day.
Well, I get to.
In the world is your,
the world is your roster.
I'm the man, right?
And I get to UNC Chapel Hill as a 17 year old freshman.
And like, there's no banners that are saying,
welcome Charlie, we're so glad you're here.
And it took me, you know, probably a whole couple of weeks
to realize that going to a place like that
with 4,000 other freshmen,
I was basically average.
Average at best even,
and there were a lot of very talented athletes,
students,
dancers,
they were better looking.
I tried to reserve the fact
that I was funnier than other people,
but I don't know that I got that one either.
Yeah.
But, you know, and what I found pretty quickly was
that I was really good at one thing
and better than everyone else at least in my dorm.
And that was drinking.
Yeah.
I was awesome.
(Rich laughing)
I was world class
and I planned on setting as many records as I could,
and that was not conducive
to making good grades or studying, or-
Did you do the fraternity thing?
I did ultimately,
and again, it dates me a bit,
but in North Carolina where I went to school,
the drinking age was 18.
Yeah.
For beer and wine when I went to college
and as I was, while I was there,
it actually changed to 19 and to 21,
but I managed to stay just in front of the curve in that.
But I joined a fraternity my second year,
and certainly wasn't their fault.
They, you know, we would,
we would party.
And I was introduced to cocaine at that point.
It was the '80s though.
Right.
It was like, it was ubiquitous.
It was as common as marijuana like always has been
or alcohol.
It just didn't seem,
it seemed like what everyone else was doing.
I tried it and it took very little time to realize that
when I would do it, you know,
I'm seeing two or three sunrises in a row without sleeping
while the other guys,
they might do whatever couple of lines or they might do,
they might do some.
And they're actually going to sleep
at four o'clock in the morning and getting up,
and going to class or doing whatever it is,
they were truly the definition of recreational users.
Right.
But there's a big difference between
sort of understanding that like kind of that clicking in
and going, oh, like I do this a little bit
differently than everyone else.
I mean, a normal person would say,
well, that's when you start to rectify this situation.
But I know for myself very early on,
I was like, I'm definitely an alcoholic,
but I would never admit that I knew in my heart of hearts,
but I was 'cause I knew that I drank differently
and I have a huge scar on my leg from a lost weekend
I spent at UNC in 1986.
(Rich laughing)
Was I there?
Where I woke up at, I don't know,
maybe, maybe we partied together.
(Charlie laughing)
Were you there in eight, yeah.
Wait, did I hit you with an ax handle?
Yeah, maybe.
Maybe you caused the scar on my leg.
I wouldn't be surprised.
(Charlie laughing)
But what happened to me was that that set in motion,
a chain of events to protect my future right
to continue to use.
It's like, oh, well, hmm, you know, I better,
I better really kind of watch myself
because I wanna continue to be able to do this.
So if it gets too outta control too soon,
then I'm gonna have to do something about it
or I'm gonna have,
somebody else is gonna tell me
I have to do something about it.
So it was all about trying to preserve your ability
to continue to be able to party.
And, of course, never being able to get that balance right,
or that mix right.
And it just continues to get worse and spiral outta control.
Well, I went to my first AA meeting
when I was 23 years old in Atlanta.
Right.
And I didn't get clean and sober until I was 29.
So that tells you something.
And so the acknowledgement of the problem.
Right.
Was there very early on.
Self-knowledge will avail you nothing.
Yeah, and right,
exactly right.
(Rich laughing)
And I absolutely kept fighting it and kept,
you know, of course, I changed my,
my plan a thousand times,
I'm not going to do drugs.
Right.
I'm just gonna drink.
I'm not gonna drink liquor.
I'm just gonna drink beer.
I mean, whatever it might be.
I did it.
I did at least seven or eight geographical changes,
which is common for addicts.
Right.
Where I would go somewhere
and I'd move to Seattle and get a new job
and a new girlfriend and a, you know,
life would be fantastic for six months.
Then you wake up and you go,
oh, shit, I brought myself with me.
I gotta move again.
Darn it.
(Rich laughing)
You know, and that would,
that would be what would happen is then,
within a year I'd be off to some other city
to do it better.
And, of course, do it exactly the same the next time,
because sure enough, there I was.
And it just took what it took the last time.
Yeah, the last time was
at least the last time up to now, as we say-
Yeah.
It was over 21 years ago,
and it was very memorable-
Because you and I are gonna go,
we're gonna go-
we're gonna go
hammered right after this.
Yeah, right after we finish the podcast.
(Charlie laughing)
(Rich laughing)
People ask me every year.
Why wait until we're done?
Let's see what we have in the cabinet.
People ask me every year,
they're like, I'll tell 'em, that's my sobriety birthday.
Like I don't celebrate my regular birthday.
Yeah.
But I celebrate my sobriety birthday.
What are you gonna do?
I'm like, I'm gonna go get shit-faced.
Right.
And they'll look at me like, "Really?"
I'm like, no, I'm not, but-
Well, people would be amazed
how many people relapse on their first year anniversary?
Oh yeah.
Because only the alcoholic will think
it's a good idea to celebrate a year of sobriety
by getting drunk.
Yeah.
You know, that makes perfect sense to me.
Well, clearly they've proven
(Rich laughing)
that they're drink like a normal person now.
Yeah.
So-
Right.
Yeah, I messed it up.
I'm messed up, you know, jobs,
and certainly my own life and wasted a lot of time.
I mean, I did my first,
my first three marathons I ever did,
really my first four were still when I was very unsober.
I'll never forget in fact,
doing my first marathon, which was Big Sur back in 1989.
And I mean, I did enter the race until about a week
before the race, did essentially no training,
but I'd been out doing some running,
and I just decided that this was another way.
This was how I could prove.
Clearly I'm not an alcoholic or an addict-
Right.
If I can go out and-
Exactly.
And do a marathon.
So I enter this-
Yeah.
Enter this race and I go,
and I do actually finish the thing.
And in a decent, you know,
I think three and a half hour time,
having no idea what I was doing
and Bur Sur was a fairly hard marathon.
And I get to the finish line and I'm looking around,
there's all these people hugging and crying.
And they're like, I mean, this amazing thing.
I make the joke, if anybody watches Dexter,
it's like Dexter trying to figure out,
when he is watching other people have emotions
and, you know, he is trying to figure out
not only why he doesn't feel that way,
but how to fake it.
Right.
And, you know,
like I desperately wanted to find somebody to hug and cry
so that I could feel fantastic about what I'd just done.
And instead, I just went out and got drunk that night.
Right, and you bring up an important point,
which is this idea.
And I relate to the,
I used to do this all the time.
This false pride that takes over.
Like you test yourself,
say, well, if I can go out and run this marathon,
I can just bang out these marathons on the weekend.
Then I must not have a drinking problem.
It's artillery to sort of use it as you will to
continue to be able to justify your drinking
and using, right?
And also like, "Hey, look what I did."
Like not only did I run,
I went out, I got completely shift-faced.
I woke up, I was hung over and I still ran a marathon.
Like, what did you do this weekend?
You know what I mean?
And it's like, there's no humility in that.
There's a complete false pride thing that takes over
that leads you in a very dark direction ultimately.
I was at the end of those first few marathons,
I could not have been emptier,
and it actually even goes back
to what we were talking about before,
'cause I had the raw emotion,
like I'd done this work.
And I had indeed scraped off those outer layers
to find that I was absolutely completely empty inside
and at least drugs and alcohol
gave some texture to the emptiness
and then being, you know, having that,
not as a crotch,
really was something I couldn't imagine at the time.
And I was doing,
I was at 25 or 6, you know, I wanted to like,
I think I bought my first house right around there,
and I bought cars and I wanted to be and was
like the top salesman at whatever job I was doing.
And those were all nothing more than my
proof that clearly there can't be any kind of a problem
if I can do those things,
then, you know, how could I possibly have a problem?
Right.
And that looming sense of emptiness is so terrifying
that the only way to deal with it is to
drink more and use more.
Fill it.
I could fill it up that way at least temporarily.
Right.
And that's of course,
what we all do in that situation.
And, you know, and it taught me,
it did teach me,
I will say it did teach me how to suffer properly.
The things I did to myself then
that's true suffering.
And when I'm out running
and whether I'm falling apart or having a great run,
I mean, even races like Badwater,
people tend to think that, oh, you did it.
And you had a good time and like a good finishing time
and you placed well and whatever.
So you had a fantastic race.
Like somehow that means that you didn't struggle
during the race-
Yeah.
And like Badwater is a race that,
I've never not thrown up at Badwater.
It's the only race I've ever thrown up in, in fact,
but I've done it every single time.
Like something about the heat mechanism there.
And just the point being that there's a series of ups
and downs during that race that are inevitable
and no matter how I plan,
they're going to happen,
those downs.
And that's what I finally had to understand.
Well, it's what I've had to understand about sobriety.
And so over 21 years,
I didn't stop me from going to prison a couple of years ago.
Right.
You know, it didn't,
it didn't stop my first marriage from falling apart.
It didn't stop,
didn't stop anything.
Life just continued to roll on.
It's just that I actually had to be present for it,
which was really.
You had to feel it.
Yeah.
Damn.
It's sort of that idea that,
sobriety doesn't promise you anything other than
a life without drinking or using.
And there's this,
this notion I think when you come in
and you have the pink cloud,
that all your problems will be solved.
And in fact, you have to sort of deal with the wreckage
and all these problems,
but you actually have to feel them.
And you're like a loose,
a raw nerve ending at first.
But the beauty of it is to be able to walk through
those challenges and those difficulties with dignity,
and that's something that I think you did in spades,
you know, in terms of your,
your prison sentence,
your jail sentence.
I mean, I've been following on Twitter for a long time,
and I remember,
you would send out these tweets and I'm thinking,
is he allowed to tweet from jail?
Or is his son doing it for him?
Like, how is this even,
I'm like fascinated by the like the,
just the pure logistics of how that happened,
but persistently putting out this positive message,
this refusal to allow this experience to control you
or to lapse into some kind of victimhood
and then to read subsequently
or during the latter stages of your tenure there,
the impact that you're having on your fellow inmates
and these guys that are starting to run
and are losing tremendous amounts of weight
and are kind of rediscovering their lives in a new way.
Yeah, it was that part of the experience
was fascinating and it is the, you know,
one of the basic tenets of addiction recovery,
which is attraction rather than promotion.
I certainly didn't go into prison and say,
Hey, all you fat guys over there,
you guys should come run with it.
Yeah.
(Rich chuckling)
They've been a great way to get my ass kicked.
It gets shanked.
Right.
(Charlie laughing)
And so instead I simply just did what I do.
I just went and I ran and I worked out and I,
I actually found people.
There was no AA in prison,
if you can believe it-
Really?
That's shocking.
That's amazing.
In federal prison.
I can't believe that.
I mean, I've done tons of panels in-
Yeah.
In jails and stuff.
So in state and in jails
and those places, absolutely.
They have pretty active programs-
But federal.
Nope, no formal AA.
Why?
Is there a reason for that or?
Well, I ended up teaching, which is funny.
Addiction recovery
classes,
and they were well attended,
but guys got certificates,
you were sort of required to do a certain amount
of that kind of work while you're there, which is good.
It's good and healthy.
But most of the guys sitting in there were there to
get the certificate and like any AA meeting though,
I would absolutely,
I just did what I would do
and hope that somebody maybe got something out of it,
but it's a,
it's an interesting thing.
So I was in Beckley federal prison and there is,
it is actually ironically a drug education prison,
meaning that they have a program where guys who,
I mean, 90% of the people there are there for drugs anyway,
mostly for selling, not for using but,
they were required if they wanted,
they had a chance to get time off of their sentence
if they completed this very long nine month
drug education program.
Right.
But basically the,
and I'm sure the,
I'm sure the prison
and the program would argue with this viewpoint.
My viewpoint was that the program basically said,
you're bad, you have destroyed your family,
you've destroyed your lives.
Don't do drugs.
Like that was the extent-
Right.
Of the education, you know?
So it wasn't really recovery oriented.
No.
It wasn't more of a
sort of a nine month shaming process.
No, you're a piece of shit.
(Rich laughing)
Don't do drugs, you know, and so stop doing that.
And while a lot of people would probably think
that's a good approach, somehow-
It's the Nancy Reagan.
Yeah.
Just say no approach.
The fact is that can be,
that's all well and good.
People can be, you know, feel strongly
about how they view people
who do drugs or have gotten in trouble
with the law for doing drugs.
But the reality is if the goal is to actually
turn out people when they come out of prison,
who are better than when they went in
and more likely to make a contribution to society,
then shaming them is certainly not the way,
to do it.
And very little is spent on treatment as we all know.
I mean, it's been proven time and again,
that every dollar that's spent on prevention
will come back tenfold,
whereas, you know, every,
every dollar that's spent on incarceration
and on sending these guys, that's why,
you know, it's another reason, Rich,
that I never, I really,
it would be embarrassing to me to complain about
my plight and how I might have felt about how,
how that all happened to me.
When I'm in there with guys, African American guys,
who got 20 year sentences
for a small handful of crack that I had in my hand,
tons of times.
And if I had been a Black man in this country,
in those times,
I would've been stopped driving the car that I would've,
that I was driving.
Right.
Which was just a Toyota 4Runner,
it's not like it was fancy,
but I would've been stopped.
They would've searched me.
They would've found that.
And I would've been the guy getting 20 years,
but I wasn't that guy.
I was the white guy driving the car in the hood
that for whatever reason,
just never that didn't happen.
I knew that,
it would've been embarrassing to me
being in their next to guys who really had their lives,
their whole lives taken away from them.
And actually the sentencing and the Congress
and everyone else is now acknowledging
that the a 100 to 1 crack to cocaine sentencing guidelines
were very possibly the most
unfavorable and really unforgivable sentencing guideline
ever handed down in any country.
And so there are some changes being made
to those guidelines now,
and acknowledgement that that was wrong.
But anyway, my-
Yeah, I mean-
My point of all that is I would,
I would've felt like a total idiot.
Yeah, but you're also a human being,
who's been incarcerated
and could very easily hang your hat on this
argument as to how you'd been wronged.
In recovery they say, justifiable anger is
a luxury we can,
we cannot afford,
but that's a stupid little-
Yeah.
Annoying saying,
and to be able to actually embody that.
And when you're in the scenario that you were in,
I mean is no small feat.
Well, I knew very quickly.
And even after I got arrested,
I mean, I'm sitting there and in this holding cell,
knowing that my life had just changed forever.
(Charlie chuckling)
And that was the night after,
the day after the Running America premiere.
Right, you had the premiere and then-
Yeah.
It was the next day.
The next day.
We should probably
complete the timeline a little bit
so that people that don't really know your story
can understand what we're talking about.
And that was made-
I mean, well, we had,
I mean, essentially your,
at the end of your drinking and using your,
essentially living outta your car
and smoking crack essentially-
Oh, yeah.
And there's some kind of altercation
that involves bullets in your 4Runner.
Yeah, yeah.
(Rich laughing)
And your son being born, that catalyzes,
you embracing sobriety.
Yeah, well, I was-
Is that accurate or?
It is.
Yeah.
In Wichita, Kansas,
which is, I always say, if you can get,
if you can get sober in Wichita,
you can get sober anywhere.
(Charlie laughing)
No, there was good sobriety there,
but it was a place where I don't know why it was different.
I just sat there on the curb that day,
looking at the police going through my car
and I'd been up for six days without sleeping or eating.
And it was another and a long line of those episodes.
And I just remember looking,
and thinking to myself,
okay, this just seems like a pretty good time to quit.
I'm not a religious person.
I'm certainly spiritual,
which is sort of one of those catch phrases these days.
And we don't have enough time to go into all of that
because we could talk all day about that.
I don't know who I was praying to,
but I absolutely said,
I would like to have this obsession removed
because I'm gonna die,
And I really wasn't,
some days I wanted to, but not that day.
And somehow that weight was lifted from me.
And I started into recovery that day
for the first time ever seriously.
I had certainly dabbled in it from time to time.
I went to a meeting that day,
and I went to a couple of meetings every single day
without missing a day for a year.
And my life changed very slowly.
It changed and I became present,
I struggled today staying present,
but at that point, everything changed.
Right, balance being the fickle,
I always say balance is the fickle lover
that is disinterested my affection.
(Rich laughing)
Well, I got,
I got sober and ran 30 marathons
in the first few years.
Right.
So clearly I had found balance.
Yeah, exactly, right?
But you go off and you kind of,
you know, for lack of a better phrase,
make history doing these incredible endurance challenges,
most notable of which is running across the Sahara
with Ray.
And what was the other one name?
Kevin.
Kevin Lin.
Documented in this incredible documentary,
which if you haven't seen it,
you should definitely check out called Running the Sahara.
That's narrated by Matt Damon.
It's captivating
and brilliant and amazing.
And in many ways,
you're sort of on top of the world,
you've got an agent at will,
the William Morris Agency,
and you're flying around giving motivational speeches
and planning your next crazy endurance adventure.
When a young man by the name of Robert Norlander
gets it into his skull,
that there's something,
there's something a little amiss
with this Charlie Engle character.
(Rich laughing)
Well, apparently being an ultra,
being an ultra runner is a-
Is a suspect in its own right.
Right.
You're suspect if you're a runner
and you're spending a lot of time training,
somebody might wanna know how it is
you're managing to make a living
if you're spending all that time running.
And that is,
that is just how it, you know,
it's how it came about.
And it was a-
He's like local IRS guy.
Yeah.
Right?
Correct.
So he's in your town, you're in the local papers
and you're getting a little attention and-
Yeah, yeah.
And he's for some reason,
he's got it in him, that he's gonna-
Yeah, he decides to start digging
and every time he hits a wall,
and again, it's difficult to go into all,
of course, even touch on the real details.
Although there'll be many of them will be in a book soon,
but the fact of the matter is the patriot act is,
is something that I learned a lot about during that time.
Because in essence, every time he hit a wall,
he was able to basically take some action
to change the investigation in a way
that allowed him to,
yeah, to just once he hit a wall.
For example, this supposedly started off
as a tax investigation.
He was curious about, how I paid my bills and my taxes,
and when he checked into it, you know what he found,
I paid my taxes.
There was no,
and I always say to people who are self-employed,
especially, I'm like,
you let the IRS look through 20 years of your tax returns,
if you're self-employed and find nothing.
I challenge you to that same thing.
But that's exactly what he found was,
was absolutely nothing.
And for some inexplicable
and, you know, I have the memos that show that,
and those all came out at trial,
and so there's no secrets there
and because they're paying my taxes,
but for some reason it didn't end there,
and that's where I'll probably never understand it.
Why?
Right.
Suddenly he decides he's gonna be a DA, right?
Like he's becoming a prosecutor.
Who's, I mean, you know,
as in his role at the IRS,
you would think, well, inquiry done, you know.
Yeah.
I explored it.
There's nothing there moving on, but-
That's his job.
And even if you don't like,
I mean, he's famously quoted
in the grand jury investigation,
he's famously quoted as saying,
if I'm riding down the street
and I see somebody driving a nice car,
and I don't think they belong in it,
I'll run their tags and pull their tax returns.
(Rich laughing)
All right.
And like, apparently,
I mean, that's a direct quote from the grand jury.
I mean, there's no-
Right.
There's no doubt about what he said,
and I was like, really?
That's where we live now?
That you can just do that.
I mean, but anyway, that's the way it went down and-
Right, and with the latitude
allowed him under the law because of the Patriot Act.
The Patriot Act, absolutely.
You read about these crazy
sort of spy novel episodes in your life
where they set you up.
There was a woman who was planted,
you would go on a date with her.
You think it's a date,
but she's wearing a wire and-
Yeah.
All kinds of craziness.
And basically I acknowledged at time,
the fact that in hindsight,
I had gotten a couple of loans,
mortgages that were, just like everyone else was getting,
I didn't know I was getting them,
just like most people didn't know they were getting.
There's stated income loans.
Stated income loans, right.
I mean, that was just what was being given.
I mean, as a borrower,
we don't go into a bank,
or I certainly wasn't sophisticated enough
to go into a bank and say, I want this type of loan.
You just go in and you fill out
whatever paperwork they tell you to fill out
and you either qualify or you don't.
And I did, you know,
I did that exactly the same as I had done
a dozen times before,
no different in any way, shape or form during that,
2005 to 2008 or whatever time period.
It's widely acknowledged now that it was much easier
to get a loan.
Look at-
Oh yeah, for sure.
I forgot who it was in the New York Times today.
I think there was,
is it JP Morgan paying another $20 billion in fines.
I mean, they've paid-
Right.
Something like a $100 billion
in fines around that whole thing.
And to say that a borrower,
not I wasn't in the real estate industry,
I was just a guy, just a guy
with a little bit of local notoriety
to think that I could somehow
manipulate the system in some way,
that I was some genius mastermind,
which anyone who knows me well,
(Charlie chuckling)
can attest that's not the case.
It's just absurd.
It's actually just it's laughable.
But what happens is, you know,
once you're in the system.
You know he investigated me for over 700 hours,
just my taxes,
and it's my opinion.
You don't do that and come up empty.
You find a way to reach-
Right.
To reach an end result
that is desirable for them.
And I think it was a little,
again, years later now,
everyone sort of understands that we're, you know,
the banks are still answering questions about what happened,
but none of them are going to prison.
Right.
Essentially they pay a fine.
Right, essentially what happens is
you become this poster boy for mortgage fraud.
Right.
For better or worse.
And technically there are some improprieties there
that allow them to say, yeah,
you violated the law here,
and let's not look at sentencing guidelines.
Let's make this guy an example because meanwhile,
you have to look at it in the context of what was going on,
contemporaneously in America.
We're in this mortgage crisis.
All of a sudden we need to point fingers at people,
and rather than taking the guy up,
JP Morgan or Goldman Sachs or Bank of America
or Countrywide or whatever,
let's look at,
let's make Charlie, you know,
let's make Charlie the bad guy.
Ironically, like the Countrywide headquarters
are like just down the street.
Oh, right.
If you want to go visit after the podcast.
(Rich laughing)
There's probably some kind of alarm go off.
You go knock on the door,
yeah, there you go.
(Rich laughing)
I'd like that guy to be doing,
he should have done my time.
There's a lot of people-
A lot of people,
There's a lot of people that would say that.
And I think we're all still waiting for those guys
to be held accountable for a lot of the things
that were going on, but whatever.
It'll never happen.
Right.
So here you are suddenly you're gonna be,
you're gonna be the guy
and kind of in retrospect now,
the revisionist history of the whole thing is it,
it backfired in the other direction
because with all of the kind of,
journalism that transpired around your tenure,
you ended up coming out,
looking, you know,
(Rich laughing)
like the victim in the whole thing.
Well, and I was,
and I mean, you won't hear me say that very often
and I don't want to dwell on that,
but what I also knew and sobriety is what taught me this,
recovery is what taught me this.
I had a choice, like when that happened,
and when I,
a good friend of mine actually said to me,
something that I was one of the greatest compliments
I've ever been given in my life like,
'cause the people around me were devastated.
Of course my family.
Right.
But my friends,
I mean, people by the hundreds were,
you know, were just didn't know what to say.
I mean, they looked at me like I had a terminal disease,
and it was like, what do you say to a guy,
who's getting ready to go off to prison?
And-
Right.
And it was me that was consoling them
most of the time.
And so my great friend, Chris Justice,
who helped me with many things.
He basically said, you're spending all your time
making us feel better instead of the other way around.
And what I figured out quickly though,
and it was again, because of,
because of my long term recovery, I believe,
I believe this and that is that I had a choice.
I could either be miserable
or I could be as positive as was possible,
and it wasn't pink cloud positive.
It wasn't like some false positive.
Like I had to say, okay,
I'm gonna find a way to make the best of this.
And I have no idea what that even means yet,
but, you know, ultimately I went in there
just saying that,
I can be one of those guys,
and I saw them every day who had long prison sentences
and they checked off the calendar every day,
and to me that would've been maddening.
I don't know if I would've made it-
Right.
Through my short time.
It was a year and a half, which is a long time,
but relatively speaking,
not that long compared to many of them.
Right, 16 months, but was the sentence longer?
Sentence was 21 months.
21 months.
And the way the federal system works
is you sort of get a,
you get a pre nearly 15% discount-
(Charlie laughing)
Right.
On your sentence.
(Rich laughing)
You get your good behavior in advance,
and if you screw it up-
They can ruin it.
They take it away.
Right.
I got you.
And then technically you,
you normally would get-
So generous of them.
(Charlie laughing)
Yeah, absolutely.
You normally would get 10% of the halfway house.
And so that's what I got to,
that's why it was a,
it was a 21 month sentence.
Basically, I had to serve 18 months of it,
but after 16 months I was released to a halfway house-
Gotcha.
In Greensboro, which actually, by the way,
it was far worse than prison.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Well, in a camp like where I was,
and basically there with non-violent criminals,
generally speaking, I mean, a lot of them-
Well, Beckley was divided.
There's was a like a minimum-
Medium, yeah.
Security and a medium.
A medium right.
And the medium, and I got to know some of those guys too,
'cause they would graduate from there.
I don't mean graduate-
Right.
Like high school,
but, you know, they would move from there if they,
if they were less than 10 years left on their sentence,
and whatever, they might come to the lower security place.
And you know, what I,
what I found was of course that,
these were almost all just regular guys.
But when I got to the halfway house,
you have guys from all security levels
that are being dumped into the halfway house.
So you got some-
Right.
Some rapists and murderers and some,
some genuine bad guys in there
and you're 30 people stuck in one room on bunk beds
and you can't leave.
It was tough.
How different is it from?
I mean, my only sort of point of context,
other than doing the occasional panel,
in downtown LA is what I see on television
or what I see in movies.
This is what,
this is the way a prison guard acts and behaves.
It's all informed by media that I've seen,
it's all crafted by a screenwriter and a director.
So how, you know,
how different is the real life experience of being
in a place like that versus,
what did you expect and how is it different?
Well, of course, I feared the worst,
you know, all the time,
I went in there on Valentine's day 2011,
that was the first day of my sentence.
And, you know, my major concern
was being someone's Valentine that night.
Yeah.
And or any night and-
Or any morning.
Or any morning or any time,
and that,
(Rich laughing)
you know, that didn't happen at least.
I'm debating asking you the question of-
Right.
You did become somebody's Valentine.
(Charlie laughing)
Well, I'll never tell.
(Rich laughing)
Yeah.
We've been sworn to see you after.
Maybe that'll be in the book,
You'll have to read the book, exactly.
(Rich laughing)
So, but it was, you know, it was very similar
in many ways to what we do see on television,
that the difference is I, of course,
being on that side of it,
got to see the human aspect of it.
I got to know guys
and I got to know their families in visitation.
I got to see their pictures and hear their stories
and hear about their lives.
And it's a funny thing about running and working out,
all of us who do that,
understand the comradery that's built.
And so every day out in the rec yard,
when we're doing whatever workout we might be doing
or running around that quarter mile loop and talking
and just commiserating,
it was fascinating to find
the similarities were far greater than the differences
and it is true.
Most of them,
the large majority of people in there
came from poor backgrounds
and they were destined for prison.
I watched this,
I watched this amazing documentary just this past week
called "The House I Live In."
It's on Netflix, by the way.
They didn't pay me to say that.
But it was so fascinating
because it really explained so much around
the history of incarceration in this country
and where, you know, where it came from,
and why we have 14,000 statutes on the books
that are actually punishable by prison sentences.
I mean, it's amazing the things that are illegal
and yet 97% of the people who are in prison
are there for non-violent crimes.
So what we do is we lock up the people that we're mad at,
not the people that we're afraid of.
And what is the percentage
of incarcerated people that's related to substance abuse?
Almost all.
It's gotta be, yeah.
Over 90% are related to drugs.
And less than 1% of those
have anything to do with the word, kingpin.
Right.
Almost all of them are just regular drug users.
And yet the lack of treatment
and rehabilitation within the system.
It's almost nonexistent.
It's shocking.
I mean, we, in this country,
we have 5% of the population of the world
in the United States.
Yet we have 25% of the incarceration in the world.
So, you know, in the free,
I don't know what the answer is,
but I know that we haven't found it.
And the tough on,
tough on crime is the words,
but it's really tough on drugs is,
is the way it plays out.
It just really means that alcohol
and other drugs have just had better lobbyists.
I mean-
Well, in the more privatized incarceration becomes,
then the K street lobbyists start lining their pockets.
And this is not going in any other direction
other than to continue to expand.
Well, if you build it,
they will fill it, you know, is how it goes.
And here's the thing.
I'm certainly a liberal at heart.
There's no doubt.
I'm a, you know, I'm a liberal guy,
but from a fiscal standpoint,
no matter which side of the political aisle you're on,
if you take a look at the economics of locking people up
for incredibly long,
you lock up a 20 year old for 20 years on a drug sentence,
that person will end up being a ward of the state
or ward of the taxpayers for the rest of their lives.
Right, and what is it?
Like $60,000 a year or something like that-
It's crazy.
Per person.
I'm a tax payer.
And that's maybe,
and that's only the hard cost maybe of what it,
feeding them, housing.
That doesn't count,
that doesn't actually take into account,
the cost of maintaining the entire system.
I mean, it's a crazy, crazy big number.
Right.
And when we were,
although I don't know when this was,
when we were flush with cash
or felt like we were in this country,
then that was fine.
Everybody gets behind tough on crime.
You don't want to be the politician that stands up and says,
we should ease up on these guys some,
but what it's done is create this situation
where now we have to pay for it.
And it's not just paying for it while they're in prison,
it's paying when they get out.
And I don't know, as your neighbor,
would you rather have the guy who,
who's actually had some strong rehabilitation
and learned a skill
and had some positive things happen as your neighbor,
'cause they're gonna get out
and they're gonna move somewhere.
Or would you rather have the angry guy who just lost
20 years of his life and feels like he was wronged
and he's just wait, basically, he's just waiting to go back.
Right.
I mean-
Well, and he can't get a job
and he's dependent upon the state to provide.
Yeah.
Recidivism rates are 70%.
I mean, that's why most guys go back.
They can't-
Right.
They just can't quite get over the hump.
And it's not even to say, I mean,
there's programs to help guys.
There's all those things,
but it's easier said than done.
I mean, for me, I get to check that box.
Right.
(Charlie laughing)
For the rest of my life.
The article that I enjoyed the most on,
all this sort of articles that are out there from
Outside, Men's Fitness, New York Times,
all that kind of stuff that,
that kind of talks about your prison experience
was the one in the Oxford American
'cause that really got at the heart of like,
this is what it's really like.
I'll put a link in the show notes up to that,
but it was a very touching piece.
Leslie Jamison wrote that,
and she was incredible.
She came to visit me,
and what's funny is it goes back to running.
Right?
Right.
'Cause you had met her at an ultra, right?
I met her at the Barkley.
I met her at the Barkley,
and she wasn't running,
but her brother was actually running the race
and she wrote a piece about him for the race.
I wrote a piece about the race for Runner's World actually,
that got put off being published.
It actually was published in Runner's World
while I was at Beckley,
(Rich laughing)
which was pretty fascinating.
Do publications like Runner's World,
are they scared of you now?
Or they-
No.
They just love the story.
Yeah, no, they love the story.
And I give David Willy and the guys at Runner's World
great, you know, great credit for recognizing that,
readers are sophisticated enough to make their own decisions
and if I can tell a decent story.
(Charlie laughing)
Right.
I mean, that's what it should be about, right?
Yeah.
If I can tell a decent story,
I mean, I used to make the joke that I'm,
I'm even with running the Sahara,
a lot of people might admire me for that,
some people really dislike me for it.
I mean, it's all over the board,
but my attitude is if something happens
where people actually have a strong opinion
and want to talk about it, I'm happy.
Yeah, it's good, right?
I still get,
I got a note last week from a guy like on Facebook,
who said, you know,
you were the biggest jerk in that movie and this and that.
(Rich laughing)
And I wrote, he gave some reasons and I wrote him back.
I said, I said, "Dude, I couldn't agree with you more."
(Rich laughing)
I said, but just realize that it's not always exactly,
exactly what you see and that's the way everything is.
Right, right.
That's the way, that's the way prison was.
That's again, I'm hoping that in writing,
I can tell that story
in a way that doesn't,
I don't wanna bore anybody
and we're not gonna go into all the details in the book of,
every minuscule thing that happened at trial or in prison.
But the book is really gonna be a running book
more than anything.
But I mean, there is room to kind of talk about all of that.
Right, so the working title is
"Running Unempty"
Running In Place."
"Running In Place."
Sorry.
Yeah.
And I had the great privilege of reading
the proposal and some of the sample materials,
the sample chapters that you've already prepared
and it's a barn burner.
When I first reached out to you,
I think I even said on Twitter,
I was like, I can't wait to read this guy's book.
Like this is the book,
like if you like "Finding Ultra,"
this is like "Finding Ultra" on steroids times a billion,
like the epic tale of Gilgamesh or something,
but I'm interested in where you're at right now
in the process.
How long is it gonna be?
And kind of the trajectory of
how you're gonna get this book done and out.
I've got a fantastic agent,
with the help of a professional team really,
we managed to put out a,
I think what is a really good proposal,
and that proposal is actually out to publishers just-
Oh, you went out with it already.
Just now literally.
Oh, cool.
Literally just now.
Oh, that's exciting.
And we've had a couple of great responses already.
Fantastic.
And I'm hoping that in the very near future,
there'll be an announcement to be made that,
you know, then it's like,
it's kinda like,
it's kind of like entering a race though,
then I actually have to write it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Which as you know.
I know.
Is-
Just one day at a time.
I wrote about,
I think I wrote about a thousand pages
when I was at Beckley.
So if I could just transfer all that over,
and it was useful, that'd be great.
But again as you know that's not the way the-
Yeah, but at least you don't,
Process works.
But it's not a,
you're not staring at a blank page,
you have all this material to work with.
I've done enough.
It's not like you don't know the story either.
Yeah, it's mine.
I can't really be wrong.
(Rich laughing)
Can I?
The question is, can I make it compelling?
And I like to think that
that it'll be,
I'm here to say as always that,
that it's a work in progress and so am I,
and there, I will never have all the answers to,
who I am and why I do things.
And I don't think any of us do.
And if I quit asking those questions, then I'm in trouble.
I'll tell you something actually,
Astacianna, who I'm lucky enough to be marrying on Saturday.
Ask me one of the hardest questions,
I've ever been asked,
at one of our first dates,
and she sort of looked at me probably wisely wondering,
what was going on with me?
And because there's all these tales of misery,
I'm good at overcoming the difficult things,
and putting myself sometimes,
some of the things I did myself,
some were done to me,
which is like most of us
and some things just happen
and I'm good at setting my mind to that.
But she asked me the question,
do I have any clue how to be happy?
Like how to just be happy?
Like if things were going fantastically,
could I just be happy?
And I thought it was the most amazing question ever
because I realized right away
that really the answer to that question was no,
I've never really understood
like how to be happy.
And I'm hoping that there's,
that there's that ability's gonna grow in me,
certainly with her, it will be forced to grow.
'Cause she's much better at it than I am,
but it's an interesting thing,
I think maybe I've relied on suffering
and my desire somehow to suffer
and find my discovery through suffering,
that that's the way I've always functioned and so.
Well, you have,
you have alcoholism, it's the ism.
Yeah.
It's the I seek misery.
Right?
But happiness,
happiness, I don't think is
a destination.
It's a process.
And I think it, you know,
I think that you get glimpses of it,
or I get glimpses of it when you can get out of yourself
and be of service.
And when you're tapped into somebody that you care about
and when you are expressing yourself authentically,
and I think that in terms of your book,
if all you do is share your experience
and you do it honestly with integrity
and you allow yourself to be
vulnerable in that process,
that it will be difficult
and you will suffer just like you do in an ultra,
but there will be a sense of satisfaction.
And I think we talk a lot about happiness,
but it's really about like,
are you gonna be a satisfied human?
I think that's more of,
that's a better sort of inquiry,
or one, at least I can relate to a little bit more.
I agree.
The fear, although it's not rational,
but it doesn't have to be rational.
The fear is somehow that if I'm a content,
like even for five minutes,
that I'm gonna lose some edge-
Right.
(Rich laughing)
Like the, oh my God,
now I'm gonna sit on the sofa
and eat popcorn for the rest of my life,
And that would just be terrible.
And it's finding, it is,
it's trying to find some sort of a balance
where I can enjoy myself.
I can enjoy just being
and not always be looking forward
to whatever that next thing is.
And I, you know,
I vowed
now, you know, that when Run2Boston
is finished this year,
I'm gonna, it's not even, so-called taking a break,
it's just gonna do nothing.
I'm gonna,
it's time to be married and to work on life actually,
instead of always working on.
Doesn't mean I won't be looking forward towards something-
Right.
At some point in the future,
but it's finding that next thing that
she and I can do together and that,
we can travel to some great place.
I mean, we took our first,
we got engaged in Puerto Rico
and it was the first time I had traveled,
traveled.
I was gonna say, out of the country.
Right.
Puerto Rico is a gray area-
Not for running related.
Exactly.
Yeah.
In more than 10 years.
That I had actually gone somewhere
if you don't count prison.
Yeah, I was gonna say,
well, Beckley-
Yeah, that was exactly right.
But you ran Badwater at Beckley.
I did.
So technically you went there to do that, right?
(Charlie laughing)
Exactly.
(Rich laughing)
(Charlie laughing)
But we had an actual vacation.
Yeah.
And now she's a former pro athlete.
So we ran every day and we,
you know, we certainly were very active,
but I wasn't there for an event.
Although the event turned out to be-
And you did-
Getting engaged.
You didn't, you know, dissolve.
No, I apparently I got through it just fine.
(Rich laughing)
It's been a strange and interesting learning curve
these last few years.
And the oddest thing about it is,
if I knew I could be here right now
getting married on Saturday,
and just all the things going on for me,
I wouldn't even change the last few years.
Right.
And the difficulties,
and you touched on it the second ago,
being at Beckley,
I had some of the most satisfying times of my entire life
while I was in there,
because there's nothing like,
you know, watching somebody else transform
and knowing that I at least had a small hand
in helping them change their own life,
whether it was losing weight,
or just running
or, working out or changing their attitude towards
how they ate.
I mean, even in prison, you know-
Right.
You've got this issue with eating all the time.
I don't know, it was just really,
it was wonderful.
Well, I think what's great about that is-
By the way-
It relates-
I don't wanna do it again, by the way.
No, yeah.
(Rich laughing)
Just to be clear.
Let's try to, yeah,
let's try to one way that,
right?
Okay, right.
What I loved about it though,
was that it really was this kind of,
using the principles of recovery in that,
you referenced it earlier,
it's a program of attraction not-
Promotion.
Promotion or recruitment.
And so you would just go out and run every day
and you weren't like trying to
get anyone else to go with you.
You're like, this is what I'm doing.
And then slowly,
these guys are starting to show up
and I love the characters.
They're like Butter Bean and Bootsy and Block.
And these guys-
Yeah.
You know, from what I can understand,
like the furthest thing from
being an athlete or being run
or some of them tremendously overweight.
And over the course of this 16 month period,
like one guy lost 180 pounds or something like that.
Yeah, yeah.
Adam, Adam.
I mean, it's so schmaltzy that it's like,
oh, what is this a Disney movie?
This is the guy
you could see the montage sequence in the movie
about how that all transpires,
but there's real beauty in that.
Well, some good guys too.
I mean that again, through whatever circumstance,
I mean, some of them are just addicts.
Some of 'em had other issues or just bad luck or whatever.
And there are a few genuine bad guys, of course.
I mean, prison isn't full of people that,
that shouldn't be there.
Right.
There's a few that should,
but generally speaking, they were just regular guys.
And what I found funny is nobody ever,
of course, came up to me.
Initially guys even made fun of me to a certain degree,
which is not unusual for me,
but through time and the fact that they saw me
continuing to run and to do these things,
they would never like approach me in the middle of,
the cha line or something like that.
They would come up to me sort of surreptitiously and say,
Hey-
Yeah, Yeah.
Man, I'm thinking about,
I've been thinking about running, you know,
what do you think I should do?
Like very quietly.
I even had a couple of the guards in there,
who came to me for running advice,
and that was totally against, you know, any-
They're not really allowed.
Any policy, no, no.
And they were, again, and those guys,
were, you know, some of them weren't good guys.
I mean, unfortunately, you take guys
and give 'em some power in a situation like that,
and there were a lot that really treated people poorly,
but there were also plenty who were
were in fact just doing their job,
and I never held that against them,
and were good guys.
And if they asked me,
how to start a running program,
I'd tell an officer just as much as I tell an inmate,
because running is running.
If you're willing to,
if you're willing to take a shot at it,
then I don't want to ever discourage anybody
from getting out there and finding what they can do.
And are you still,
are you in touch with these guys still?
You know, that's the irony.
No, is the answer,
and the reason is not because I don't wanna be,
but it's not allowed.
Oh, former inmate-
Yeah.
Can't correspond with somebody who's inside?
Correct.
I didn't know that.
Yeah.
And actually, technically, I can't,
I mean, it's been interesting for me just
because I'm easy to find
out here in the world.
And so if somebody that I was in there with
wants to find me
through whatever social media or anything else.
Right.
It's pretty much impossible to stop,
although I do laugh every once in a while,
I get some kind of note from somebody
and I'll tell you the truth,
it'll be their real name.
And I've no idea who it is
because they've got a name,
like a ball game.
It's not by the ball.
(Charlie laughing)
Right, but it's interesting.
It's not allowed, so it's been,
it's weird and frustrating.
It'd be like going to college
for years with guys or being in a fraternity
or being on some team sometime.
And then when that's over,
never being allowed to have contact with them again.
I don't know, I mean, I assume.
Can you go visit or no?
No, God, they won't you visit.
No, I can't visit, I can't vote, I can't-
Is the rationale is that you're,
you could be some sort of proxy for them to
take care of business in the outside world on their-
Yeah.
Behalf or something.
Yeah, not only that,
it's just that technically,
if you have supposedly bad guys that are all
continuing to have contact with each other.
Right.
Then that could somehow lead to something.
I mean, the here,
(Rich laughing)
the irony I've always found in that is that,
prison is essentially criminal college.
I mean, I don't wanna say what I could do
because I probably get myself in trouble,
but the stories you hear and the things that you learn-
You learn some skills.
You learn how to do.
You're got some skills.
(Rich laughing)
I mean, you know,
my drug past is gonna be right where it belongs
and that's in the past forever,
but you know, the ways people do things,
I mean, and I will say that,
meth is the killer of today,
very much like other drugs have been in the past,
but it's the scourge of the earth right now.
And you can make it in a bathtub.
And so it's bad news, but I mean,
I guess the idea is that they don't want guys
being able to get together when they get outta prison.
And there's, you know,
there is some logic to that,
but once you've shoved them together
to basically share information
in tight quarters for months or years together,
that ship is kind of sailed.
Right.
But so it's frustrating though.
I mean, I got,
these guys who were my friends, are my friends.
They'll always be my friends.
I mean-
Right.
From that time.
I don't have any idea what's happened to any of them
at this point.
And so we kind of glossed over the fact
that you actually ran your version of Badwater
when you were in prison.
You had to do it over a couple days, right?
I did.
'Cause they really let you run
a couple hours a day.
Yeah, well, they discourage,
I think the rules probably even say,
you're not supposed to run more than
three miles at any time or something and-
They made an exception for you.
Well, they, you know,
they didn't really make an exception.
I just sort of did it,
but it is, I still had to go inside for count.
And obviously, I had to sleep inside.
But they let you go out in the yard all day
and do it?
Camps, yeah.
A camp is interesting because you do have,
you have jobs.
I mean, my job working in recreation.
And so I had to like clean the pool tables every morning
and there's some, I had specific jobs,
and then I taught classes.
The addiction recovery classes, those kinds of things.
But in a sense at a camp,
there is, you know,
there's guys in there that have to work.
I was lucky enough that,
I had some support, it was my own money,
but I had some,
I had the ability to get some money every month.
And then, I mean, there's a limit to that.
It's very complicated.
But suffice it to say some guys in there,
there's nobody that,
they don't have anybody on the outside.
Right.
If they don't earn $10 or a $100
or whatever it might be that month,
then they can't go buy a new pair of tennis shoes-
Right.
At the commissary,
or they can't get snacks or coffee or anything else.
And so those guys work.
Right.
And very often what you'll see,
not to be too detailed, but where you see a camp,
you'll usually see like a medium present,
a higher level security.
And it's really a lot of the guys at the camp,
it's their job to actually take care of the grounds
or whatever it might be
for the higher level security presence.
So it's a very intricate, interesting, weird twisted system.
For me, I was able to teach my classes
and to do those things in a way that allowed me,
a lot of freedom during the day.
Get quite the money there.
Yeah.
And so, I mean, I could go,
I could go run so-
You're just running around a yard,
that's what?
Like a quarter mile in perimeter-
Yeah,
Or whatever.
I call it a goat path 'cause it even had a hill.
So I had to decide, did I want to run
the direction that meant that I went up a sharp steeper hill
on one way or the other direction had a much-
Yeah, you had that short, steep down,
but you had a much longer gradual up, I don't know.
It was very, like any runner I overthought of-
I was laying in bed at night,
like pondering this deep-
I should go that way.
Decision that you have to make.
Is that way faster?
(Rich laughing)
Is the other way faster?
But, you know, I got to where I was doing.
I mean, I did speed work.
I did all kinds of stuff in there.
And even was able to,
I ran a few five minute miles in there
and did some things I hadn't done for many, many years.
So just because I had the time to do it.
And you know, I read.
Yeah, you're not gonna be a return
any phone calls or anything?
No.
I read 150 books, I wrote every day.
I did my best under really stressful circumstances
to take care of my body, but also my spirit,
and that was done by helping other people.
And look, you know, from being in recovery,
talk about helping other people,
sounds very giving and very generous.
And we know in addiction recovery
that the thing that I can do that is,
is absolutely the most selfish thing I can do
and best for me is to help someone else.
Right.
And so I set my sights on,
on doing that and still, hopefully still do.
I get a lot of requests to speak and to do things,
talk to kids and adults alike.
And I try to never say no to those things
just because I think it's what I'm required to do.
Yeah, if you wanna,
if you wanna keep it-
Yeah.
You gotta give it away.
Exactly.
So how did the Twitter thing work?
You gotta answer this.
Drive me crazy.
Yeah, so I had a,
the way prisons work these days is they do federal prisons
are equipped with computers these days.
It's very expensive and it's very limited,
the amount of time you can spend on it.
So what I would do is
I would actually write my tweets in advance
and sometimes I would mail them out in a letter.
Sometimes I would get on email,
but that was heavily, that was monitored by,
by the system.
But it wasn't illegal.
It's not, you know, again,
it did turn into a,
they didn't care for it.
Let's just put it that way.
They weren't happy about the fact
that you're tweeting from.
No, they weren't happy about it.
But the fact of the matter is,
and someone else had to actually-
Type the tweet.
Exactly.
Right?
But that happens every day,
all over the place and it's not illegal,
and I wasn't, you know,
if I had been sending out posts that said,
here's how you sneak some contraband into me.
Yeah.
Or naming the guard by his name and-
Or yeah, anything
(Rich laughing)
or even an inmate by his name,
then that's not cool.
I wouldn't have done that.
But it was all generic.
I mean, my favorite one was I did
this whole little series called Overheard.
I remember that.
Yeah.
And there was some,
there was some funny stuff,
because guys in there, would just say,
say some crazy things.
I don't even know if I can give an example.
And I'm trying to remember.
Well, I'm standing in line for lunch one day.
And these two guys are talking in front of me,
and one of 'em looks at the other one and says,
now, wait a minute.
Exactly what part of the cow does the liver come from?
(Rich laughing)
Because like we were having liver and onions that day.
And another guy asked me,
he asked me, he is like, now, you know,
how many laps around this track equals a cupcake?
Right.
Things like that.
And I mean, they're just,
they're great, funny, genuine questions and some,
and also some heart wrenching things,
guys who-
I have no doubt.
Who hadn't seen their kids for 10 years
and they're getting to visit that day and things like that.
I mean speaking of that,
how has that kind of colored your relationship
with your sons?
I mean, how has that?
Man.
How's that impacted?
Well, my kids are doing great,
but I couldn't have,
I couldn't have been taken away from them.
I mean, is there ever a good time,
but they were teenage boys and, you know,
one of them, my youngest is now a freshman
at UNC in Chapel Hill
and he's, you know, to say they survived it
and got through it okay,
is just to acknowledge the physical manifestation
of what happened.
I mean, you know, they're still alive.
They're alive.
They're doing their thing,
they're living their lives,
but it's a pretty scary thing
for teenage boy to just have their dad taken away.
And my older sons had some addiction issues himself
and he's doing fantastically right now
and he's a personal trainer
and I'm hoping that both of them get to come out
during Run2Boston and spend some time out on the road
and to helping out.
You know, they're doing well,
but it, you know, it destroyed my family,
and the shock waves from that
will probably never go away fully.
But I say to them the same thing that I'd say to anybody,
nobody can ruin my life, except for me.
(Charlie laughing)
Nobody gets the right to do that.
Not some federal agent,
not prison, not a prison guard, not anybody.
I'm fully capable of messing up my own life.
Right.
But to kind of come out of Beckley
and carry that pain of knowing that,
what happened really impacted those boys.
Yeah.
You know, in a profound way.
And how do you kind of move forward with that?
Well, and as a father, they, you know,
I called them and I wrote,
and I would do all the things that I could.
And it was, at the beginning,
we had a lot of contact and as time moved forward,
what I was, and this is my kids are loving boys
who both will hug and kiss me in public.
Right.
And I judged that as success as a father,
but they to protect themselves actually,
had to like withdraw from me to a certain degree.
I mean, it was almost like too painful to hear from me.
Right.
And I tried to respect that
and to not try to be,
and one of the hardest things to do is to try to
stay in touch, but also try to not be like a parent.
Like I couldn't tell them what to do-
Right.
From the situation I was in.
And, you know, again,
and I watched other guys, I learned from other guys,
I had a guy, black, who was listed on your list there.
And he had a son,
who was one of the top basketball players in the country.
And he's the first one who said to me,
"Man, you gotta let it go.
You gotta let it go."
'Cause I'd call, and I wouldn't hear back.
I'd go weeks sometimes without hearing from my own kids.
And he'd say, "You gotta let it go.
They're in their own pain right now,
and you just gotta let 'em get through it.
You can't save them and they can't save you.
Do your time, don't let your time do you."
Right, right.
And there's this incredible dichotomy
between your Beckley, which equals imprisonment
and running, which is ultimate freedom, right?
These two worlds butting up against each other
and your ability to find freedom through running
during your imprisonment.
It's kind of like this Venn diagram kind of situation.
And I was thinking about that last night
when I was going to bed,
like the two extremes butting up against each other
and somebody who's used to experiencing that kind of freedom
going all the way to the other side.
Well, and I had had a close friend
who said to me, before I went to Beckley,
and he was honest with me.
He said, you know, I can't imagine anybody less suited
to lose their freedom than you, because I am,
and in a way,
even my conviction in a way
was an attack of lifestyle,
because my lifestyle is not normal.
I don't, you know, I've never worked like nine to five,
not because I just really have proven myself
very incapable of being able to do it,
and so it's really a shortcoming.
It's not a anything else.
But I always sacrificed some security and money
and those things to maintain my freedom.
Right.
Because that's what I wanted.
I wanted to be able to go run or to go travel
or go to a race or go do those things
when I wanted to do it.
And that was more important to me
than having money in the bank and-
So the irony
(Charlie laughing)
is all the more palpable.
Yeah, and I look at, you know what?
It's the same reason that just a couple of days I got up
at five o'clock in the morning to go run
around a track in North Carolina for 10 hours in training
and working on my pacing, as I was saying.
I did that because I want to
prove to myself, not to anybody else,
but that I can do the things that are are difficult
and that I don't want to do.
And that I know I'll be stronger if I can do it.
And prison forced me to face that,
a thousand times over.
Well, yeah, and it's a way of sort of
staying connected to that experience, right?
It's sort of like the,
the homeless guy who's given a bed
and still sleeps on the floor.
Yeah.
Yeah, you almost don't want to get too comfortable.
And I will say it and you know, I don't,
I ever like to be a fear monger,
but I never imagined something like that
could have ever happened to me.
And most people can't,
most people don't go through their lives thinking,
oh man, at any time I could be arrested and go to prison.
(Rich laughing)
(Charlie laughing)
And yet,
and not to get off on another big tangent,
you look at all the stuff going on with Edward Snowden
and just the, you know, all the things being disclosed now.
It's an interesting place we live in these days
where there's very little privacy.
There's very little, that's not suspect,
and somehow we've become afraid of our own shadows,
and that somehow justifies that,
that nothing should be private any longer.
It's a very bizarre mashup,
because on the one hand,
we've never had more access to more information.
So there's a level of transparency that
you would think would translate into
sort of greater personal sovereignty, et cetera.
And yet at the same time we have this clampdown
kind of happening
or this consolidation of governmental power
that we're all kind of signing off on
willingly kind of volunteering for it.
And in a very Orwellian kind of sense that we,
people say, well, the NSA can
access your iPhone and it can turn on your camera
and the microphone and listen to you.
And everyone's like, okay, all right,
so what are we doing tonight?
We're just sort of yawning over this whole thing and.
(Rich laughing)
I think we feel powerless.
It's like, well, what am I supposed to do?
I guess I'll enjoy my day or-
I'm not gonna give up my iPhone.
Yeah, yeah, exactly.
Forget about that.
(Charlie laughing)
(Rich laughing)
Well, and it is,
we laugh about it but it is,
it's a question that I think.
I mean, I'm sort of enjoying watching it in the media
because it's become,
it's become a really hotly debated topic as it should be,
and I don't have the answers and I consider myself to be,
I consider myself to be a true patriot.
I mean, I am a patriot.
I certainly believe in all the basis
of what this country was built on and its freedoms.
And I think it's very debatable that we even
resemble any of that,
vision that our forefathers had these days,
and some of that is inevitable change
that's come through growth and technology and in other ways,
but some of it's a psychological shift
that we're just comfortable
and we're just kind of okay with the stuff that,
that we feel powerless to control.
And, you know,
I don't have the answers either-
I don't either.
But I know that,
I know that asking the questions
and continuing to talk about it is really important.
I think people are a little fed up
and worried though
about where the direction it's all heading.
And I'm glad we should be worried.
But we're not
sort of rallying in the streets like Vietnam era.
No.
We're too distracted.
We're too busy for that.
We're too, well, we're busy,
but we're busy doing what?
Yeah.
We're busy distracting ourselves with
technology and convenience.
Yeah, yeah.
And disposable content.
And running.
(Rich laughing)
Well, I'll just out running anyway.
Very good, yeah.
(Charlie laughing)
No, well, we've been going for almost two hours.
I don't wanna keep you too much longer, but we do,
I do wanna say, could sort of,
in the wake of getting out of Beckley,
it was a mere year later where you show up at Badwater.
Right?
And I mean, what were your expectations
returning to that race?
I wanted to be under the radar,
like as much as I possibly could be,
which is at that point.
Which is not being possible.
Yes.
Especially at Badwater, I mean.
But Chris Kostman the race director,
who I consider a friend and a great guy and-
He lives down the street here.
Oh, you saw him right?
I saw him at the supermarket the other day.
Yeah, yeah, in the Canyon area.
And actually, we don't have time to talk about it today,
but everybody out there should Google Badwater right now.
Right.
And then national parks and all that stuff.
Well, I tweeted, I tweeted about that.
I mean, I'm sure you saw that article about-
I did.
The radiation and that caused-
Yeah.
A big reaction with people,
because it's kind of a suspect story,
basically there's not gonna be any adventure core racing
in Death Valley.
Death Valley.
They have their permits.
Yeah, yeah.
We not rubber stamped.
It's crazy.
The first time.
I mean, the economic impact alone in Death Valley
is fantastic.
And the tourism,
I think that tangentially comes from
the notoriety that a race like Badwater has.
Yeah.
I mean, it brings people
from all over the world.
Yeah.
They'd have see this place.
They have valley.
Yeah, so it's gonna-
I mean do you have any behind the scenes
knowledge about that, that you can impart or not?
I really don't,
although that I know that every summer
there's a lot of Germans around in Death Valley.
(Charlie laughing)
It always fascinate me.
What?
They're in Badwater.
I don't know if you noticed this.
Well, all the kids that work in the restaurants
in the hotels are all-
Yeah, yeah.
From strange foreign countries
doing their like year abroad.
And I'm like, you got sent here?
Right.
This is your American experience,
like stuck in the middle of the desert at age 19.
Yeah, yeah.
Like what do you guys do all day
when you're not working?
Well, it's a you know,
and Badwater is a great race for a lot of reasons.
It's certainly are very difficult race,
but it is like most big ultras.
It's a family, you go to Western states,
you go to Leadville any of these,
you tend to see the same people generally over and over.
And it's this big celebration,
really of something difficult and interesting and beautiful.
And for no reason that's been taken away for this year.
I mean, literally for no reason.
And hopefully, people will,
at least write to the right appropriate people
and complain.
But anyway, to my race this past year, I went there.
Chris gave me the race number two.
Like he assigned to me, number two,
And usually race numbers are assigned
based on your previous years finished.
Previous years finished, yeah.
So obviously that wasn't the case for me.
So I don't actually know this,
but I assume whoever was second the year before
didn't come
last year,
otherwise they would've been assigned number two.
So whoever that was didn't make it in the last year,
so he gave me number two,
which to me instantly put like tons of extra pressure,
like there was some expectation.
And in fact, somebody before the race,
I overheard a comment that someone made,
a woman made that,
that I didn't deserve number two.
She didn't know I could hear her.
Oh, wow.
Yeah, and so I was like,
I will admit to sort of going, grr, okay.
But I really went there with a,
I think a good conservative plan.
I went there to win the race though.
I would never have said that out loud
and never will before a race,
but in my mind, that's the mindset that I,
I had to have.
And I was fortunate enough to run a time that
that actually was fast enough to win
a whole lot of the years in the past.
Right, and break the masters record.
Correct?
Yeah.
Yeah, I actually broke it by three hours and had a,
if there's any such thing as an easy race at Badwater,
I certainly had the easiest one I had ever had.
I saw you a couple times,
you didn't look like it was easy.
(Charlie laughing)
You didn't look like,
you didn't look relaxed.
[Charlie] Really?
You do not look relaxed.
Dang it, that's-
Yeah, really bad.
(Charlie laughing)
But you were killing it the whole time.
I was happy to see you.
That's 'cause there's stuff.
I remember what's the?
Is it what's the town where you come in
and you get all the ice.
Well, there's stove pipe.
I think a stove pipe.
Yeah.
It was like three in the afternoon
when the heat was really dialed in.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I saw you,
I was getting ice for Dean and I saw you coming through
and you ran into the bushes
to go to the bathroom or something like that
and running by.
And I was like, wow, you're really up there, man.
You were killing it, but you didn't look like you,
it wasn't like, you're like smiling and waving.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Like it was really hot.
Well, my crew and Astacianna,
I was really just trying to impress.
(Rich laughing)
I was really just trying to impress her.
She's laughing over that.
That's the only thing I was trying to do
was to impress her.
So I had to look good.
(Astacianna laughing)
Right.
But the fact is I do,
my crew always knows that I actually,
I joke the whole time and I, even if I'm miserable,
I do enjoy the experience tremendously,
and I like being out there.
But this year, I don't know.
Two things happened,
I think that that made me have a great race.
Maybe three, if I just count
having an awesome girlfriend at the time,
but she taught me how to hydrate properly,
which it sounds like a funny thing but-
Yeah, for a guy who,
the guy who ran across the Sahara Desert-
Yeah.
Needs to be told how to hydrate.
Well, I used to show up
in Death Valley every year
and I'd maybe start drinking extra water a few days before.
And certainly, when I got out into that dryness
and hotness, I'd ramp it up.
The fact is,
what I figured out was my dehydration was chronic.
And that as a runner, I'm almost,
I never had done a great job,
so a couple months before that race.
I really thanks to her,
started focusing on hydration.
The other honestly is it was the shoes,
I actually switched to Hokas
and I had run in some fantastic shoe brands before
that had supported me well, Newton, most recently,
and they're fantastic brand with great-
But Newton is the opposite of Hoka.
They are.
And I really, you know, for ultra,
for someone my size, I'm a little bigger than,
than most of the guys that were up there
where I am in the race,
and Hoka being a fairly new brand.
I never had an experience like that in my life.
I mean, I actually ran the next day after Badwater.
Right.
And two days later,
I ran five miles with no pain.
Wow.
And I'd been in the wheelchair before,
after Badwater with a variety of other brands,
because it's just a hard race.
Hard thing, yeah.
Yeah, it's a hard race.
It's hot and you get dehydrated and everything else.
So hydration made a difference.
And again, I would be disingenuous
if I didn't admit having something to prove.
I went there fearful that I would fall apart.
I hadn't done the race in a few years.
I was 50 years old and I was like going.
Deep down, I was like,
should I really be doing this again?
Right.
Or should I, you know,
I think people expected me just to go out,
and be just part participant.
Right.
And I went out and was lucky enough
to have a good day and race well and have fun doing it,
and actually feel good when it was over,
and I've never had that experience.
Yeah,
and I think you surprised a lot of people too.
I think there were a lot of people there
that didn't expect you to perform at that level.
Yeah, and I was probably one of them,
but, you know,
(Rich laughing)
I don't know.
I mean, I don't,
if you go into Badwater
or any race like that ever thinking,
you're going to do a certain thing,
you're probably gonna get your handed to you.
So I knew that if I kept a good plan and as always,
I was pretty far back in the pack halfway through
and I didn't start going faster.
I just maintained and managed to catch.
Yeah, the front pack was pretty aggressive.
They were.
Overly aggressive.
And usually a few of them will fall off.
And that happens every year,
they're going after it.
But it was a great experience.
Again, I credit Chris Kostman
and the Badwater family for welcoming me back.
And there was no, you know,
(Charlie chuckling)
there was never any discomfort around any of that.
And I had a blast.
I had a blast.
I hope the 2015, I get to do it again.
Yeah, so they're gonna do it.
They're gonna have the quote unquote,
"Badwater race."
Yeah.
They're just not gonna do it in Badwater, right?
Yeah, correct.
So it's gonna be out like an salt and sea area
or something like that.
Correct.
Chris will find a way.
Yeah.
He'll find a way to make it happen
and to make it a good, good event.
I mean, he's a brilliant, tough race director.
Yeah.
That puts on safe,
really, really wonderful events.
And I hope, I know he'll do the same this year,
even without Death Valley.
Speaking of events that go from very low points
to very high points,
you've been public in talking about this expedition
that you've wanted to do going from what is it?
The Dead Sea to the top of Everest.
Yeah.
I mean, are you shelving that for now?
Well-
Or is that still on the bucket list?
It is very much still on the bucket list
and it's something that I would like to do
on all seven continents to go from the lowest point
on each continent to the highest.
And it'll probably, if I get to do it,
it'll take the rest of my life and all likelihood.
I've promised that for this year,
we'll get through Run2Boston
and kind of focus on life as much as possible
for the rest of the year
and on hopefully finishing a book
and doing those things.
But I love this metaphor of lowest to highest
because I feel like I've been
at that lowest point many times.
Except for you.
It's not this linear thing.
Your courses should go,
they should go high, low, high, low, high, low.
(Charlie laughing)
(Rich laughing)
They should be a lot of up and down.
Well, if I could put all seven continents-
Yeah.
Together on the same expedition,
that would happen I guess.
There You Go.
But I absolutely am still,
that's still on the agenda,
sponsors and finding, you know,
finding companies that and angels out there too,
that support the things that I believe in
is important to me.
And certainly something that, you know,
that I'm always looking for those partnerships.
And I've been very lucky in the past to find good ones,
and people that believe in what I believe in,
and I'm confident that will happen again.
Cool.
Yeah.
That sounds like a good place to end to that.
So now do I get to ask you some questions?
Well, that'll be the next time.
Okay, all right.
Or we can go running now and you can do that.
(Charlie laughing)
That'd be great.
Yeah.
(Charlie laughing)
But if you want, you should start your own podcast.
You're a radio host, you do a podcast,
I'll start a network, you can join my network.
All right, that'd be great.
I would do it in a heartbeat.
Yeah, I'm sure, you know, plenty of characters,
you could invite people.
I know a few.
(Rich laughing)
Cool, all right.
So running in place, coming to bookstores
probably next year,
Run2Boston.
If people wanna support, follow,
do you have like a donate,
can people donate?
People wanna support this.
Is there a place for them to go online
and learn a little bit more about?
Absolutely, yeah.
So just, I mean, it's pretty simple Run 2 Boston
and the to is the number two.
So Run2boston-
.com.
Because of Andre, .com,
and @run2boston on Twitter.
We actually just got that handled today.
Oh, you did?
You know somebody else actually.
I would imagine somebody would, yeah.
Well, but it was just a guy.
But they weren't using it.
It was a guy, it was an Italian guy,
run Boston a few years ago.
He had one follower
(Rich laughing)
and didn't ever post anything and so we got that.
And then there's a Facebook page that just went up.
My first article on the online,
the digital version of runnersworld.com.
Right.
I mean, really runnersworld.com
is the best place to follow it,
To follow it.
Because they're gonna not only
post the things that I do, but their own stuff,
and most runners are there anyway.
So it's an easy way to follow it.
And there will be at least one post a week written
by Andre and I, separately.
We're telling our own kind of stories.
And you're documenting this on film, are you?
Absolutely.
Have your crew all sorted out for that.
And, you know, yes,
but it's gonna be a much lower key affair
than certainly not a running the Sahara.
And not even at this point running America,
it's really just,
it might just meet me with my handicam-
Right.
And out there talking,
but maybe some GoPros attached to some things,
but it's,
you know, this time,
I certainly want to tell a story,
but I'm gonna do it more through,
through writing and through the Runner's World portal,
generally speaking,
just because they've been great about
wanting to help tell the story.
And obviously, they're fully invested in
the story of Boston,
and of the purpose behind Running 2 Boston-
Of Course.
And helping to tell an organic story,
that one doesn't need any embellishment.
Right.
It's just a,
it's a poignant story on its own.
And so, yeah, it can be run2boston.com
or just the runnersworld.com site
will always have an update.
And absolutely, we hope that people will,
will sign on to receive daily updates.
And the one thing about running for 44 days in a row
is there's, you know, you can ignore a couple of days.
Yeah.
And you don't feel like you've missed very much.
Are you gonna have any like a live GPS tracking
kind of thing?
Absolutely.
So you can, that's cool.
Yeah.
So we'll have some mechanism that will,
there's a couple of possibilities there
with some of the apps that are out there.
Right.
And other ways of doing the tracking.
So yeah, people can get on anytime and see where we are.
Including the NSA.
Yeah, exactly.
Well, they're welcome to watch.
And Robert Norlander.
Absolutely.
He will be watching very intently.
(Charlie laughing)
(Rich laughing)
I'm sure.
When I left Greensboro, he apparently took up running so.
Oh, he did?
I love that.
Yep, yep.
It was interesting.
You guys are gonna be buddies.
We are, we're gonna run together someday.
I fully expect that.
Yeah, I would like to see that actually.
Cool.
All right, and if you want to just know
a little bit more about Charlie in general,
charlieengel.com, right?
Yeah.
And on Twitter @CharlieEngel.
E-N-G-L-E.
correct.
And go to richroll.com on the page
where I'm gonna host this episode.
I'll put up a bunch of links to some of those news articles
like the New York Times and Outside,
and the Oxford American one,
which is my favorite and other good stuff, including,
and the Run2Boston site and all that kind of stuff.
Great.
Cool.
Perfect.
All right, man.
So we'll get you back on the road
so you can go enjoy your wedded bliss.
Absolutely, I'm ready.
Thanks again for dropping in.
I'm glad it worked out.
Thanks Rich for having me.
I'm looking forward-
Yeah.
To coming back someday.
Yeah, absolutely.
When you finish the run and break the record,
you gotta come back.
That's a deal.
And then you gotta come back again
when your book comes out.
That's a deal.
Happy to do it.
Anything I can do to help with the book stuff too.
Let me know.
Well, we figured out we have a lot of problems
to solve out there.
You do.
And I think we can do it so.
All right, good.
So yeah.
Cool man.
All right, best of luck, man.
I can't wait to-
Thank you.
Follow you online for this.
Thank you, I appreciate it.
All right, man, peace plants.
(bright music)